APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE IN
RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AS WE COMPLY WITH THOSE
ORDERS WERE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WE WERE ALSO LIVE
STREAMING THE HEARING TODAY
SOME MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
MEMBERS OF MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC OTHER MEMBER STAFF MAY
FOLLOW ALONG FROM A SAFE
DISTANCE AS A REMINDER TO
EVERYONE OUT THERE TODAY'S
HEARING CONSISTS ONLY OF ITEMS
THAT ARE ON SUSPENSE FILE. ALL
THESE MEASURES HAVE ALREADY HAD
A HEARING BY THIS COMMITTEE
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT EVERY
MEASURE HAS HAD A HEARING WITH
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY BOTH FOR AND
OPPOSITION AS NOTED IN THE
DAILY FILE THAT THIS THE
SUSPENSE FILE HEARING IS A VOTE
ONLY HEARING. WITH NO TESTIMONY.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY FELLOW
MEMBERS THEIR STAFF AND MY
STAFF ON THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. FOR ALL THEIR
ASSISTANCE AND WORK ON THESE
IMPORTANT MEASURES. BUT ALSO
LIKE TO GIVE A SPECIAL THANK
YOU TO OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR
BATES AND HER PHYSICAL STAFF
FOR THEIR AMAZING COOPERATION
AND COLLABORATION. THROUGH
DIFFICULT AN INTERESTING YEAR.
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A FEW BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENTS
ABOUT HOW WE WILL PROCEED. TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
MEMBERS AND STAFF CAN FOLLOW
ALONG. WE WILL BE MOVING
QUICKLY THROUGH THE AGENDA
ALPHABETICAL IN OLD IN AUTHOR
PORTER. PLAY COULD PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION AS WE WILL ONLY BE
ADDRESSING MEASURES THAT WILL
BE UP FOR A VOTE THIS MORNING
IF YOU DON'T HEAR ME TAKE UP A
PARTICULAR MEASURE. THAT BILL
IS HELD UNDER SUBMISSION. I
ALSO WILL ANNOUNCE THE AUTHOR
MEASURE NUMBER AND PROVIDE A
BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF THE
AMENDMENTS. TO THE MEASURE
BEFORE WE TAKE A VOTE-
FOLLOWING THE HEARING WE WILL
BE POSTING THE HEARING REULTS
AND THE ACTIONS TAKEN ON EACH
MEASURE. ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AT W. W. DOT. S. A. P.
R. DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT GOV.
THAT'S W. W. DOT S. A. P. R.
DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT GOV. IN
ADDITION FOR ANY BILLS THAT ARE
BEING AMENDED TODAY. WILL BE
HOSTING AN ADDENDUM ANALYSIS
WHICH INCLUDES A SUMMARY OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND THE REVISED
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THE BILL.
ALSO AT THE END OF THE HEARING
I WILL BE ANNOUNCING SOME TO
YOUR BILLS. SO THAT'LL ADD A
LITTLE SUSPENSE. TO THE
SUSPENSE. CALENDAR SO PAY
ATTENTION AS WELL. SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO RIGHT TO STOP
WISHING A QUORUM. MR SCHECK
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR FORTINO
I AM HERE FORTINO HERE CENTER
BATES. BATES HERE SENATOR
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE SENATOR
JONES HERE JONES HERE CENTER
COM LONGER. CENTER CAMARGO HERE
CENTER LAYERS HERE UNDER
LAYERED HERE CENTER BY CAL SKI.
HERE CENTER CASKEY HERE WE HAVE
SEVEN AT. WE HAVE SEVEN
MEMBERS- MEMBERS- WE ARE GOING
TO DO SOME ROLL CALL VOTES
INITIALLY TO ESTABLISH SOME-
SEP VOTES AND THEN ONCE WE
ESTABLISH OUR VOTES- AS WE GO
THROUGH THE CALENDAR I'M GOING
TO SAY SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE ON.
A PARTICULAR BILL SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO DO A ROLL CALL AND
EVERYTHING ONCE WE ESTABLISH
OUR PATTERNS OKAY. SO WE'RE
GONNA GO RIGHT TO OUR FIRST
AUTHOR. WHICH IS SENATOR ALAN-
SP FORTY FOUR ON SEQUEL- THIS
IS A DO PASS. AND WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE A ROLL CALL ON SP FORTY
FOUR. SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR
THE MEASURE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER FORTINO
HI FORTINO FIVE BATES HI BATES
FIVE BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI
JONES. COME UNDER I FROM AUGUST
BY LAYERED BY LAYERED HI KELSEY
HI MAKOWSKI ARE VETERANS EXPO
THAT BILLS OUT SIX VOTES.
REMOVE ON A SENATOR ALLEN SP
SIXTY SIX CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
FUTURE TRANSPORTATION
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES IT IS A DO
PASS AND WE ARE TAKING A ROLL
CALL VOTE MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL SIXTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTERPOINT TINO HI
FORTINO FIVE BATES HI BATES HI
BRADFORD BRADFORD ALL RIGHT
JONES HI JONES- I COM LAGER HI
KAMAGRA LAYERED BY LAYERED
ARTWORK OWSKI HI MAKOWSKI I
HAVE SEVEN VOTES. THAT IS ALFA
SEVEN ZERO WE'RE MOVING ON
ALLEN SP EIGHTY THREE SEA LEVEL
RISE REVOLVING LOAN PROGRAM
THAT IS A DO PASS WITH
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT
CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION AND ROLL CALL
PLEASE. SENATE BILL EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FORTINO HI FORTINO. FIVE
EIGHTHS OF LOADING. BRADFORD
ALL RIGHT BRAD HI JONES HI
JONES HI CAMARGO I FROM LAGER
FIVE LAYERED. LAYERED I WORK
OWSKI HI MY CASKEY ARE MEASURED
SIX VOTES THAT IS OUT WITH SIX
VOTES. WERE MOVING TO SP TWO
THREE FIVE ON INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
THIS IS A DO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO MODIFY
DEFINITIONS AND MAKE OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES. THAT IS A-
HI CAN SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE ON
S. P. SIXTY SIX THAT BLUE BILLS
APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY SEVEN ZERO.
MOVING ON SP THREE FOR THREE ON
SOME RECYCLING SYMBOL THAT IS A
DO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO LIMIT MATERIAL
EXAMINED BY RECYCLE- IF I COULD
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR S. P.
THREE FOR NOW WE HAVE TO DO A
ROLL CALL ON THIS ONE. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL
CALL ON SP THREE FOR THREE
MISSED SYMBOLS AND SALT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATE BILL THREE
FOUR THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR FORTINO HI FOURTEEN HI
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI JONES L. JONES NO
LONGER HI COME ANDRADE LAYERED
LAYERED MACKENZIE HIGH
MACKENZIE ARE FIVE TO TWO THAT
IS OUT FIVE TO TWO WE'VE NOW
ESTABLISHED ARE TWO PATTERNS R.
S. B. THREE FOUR THREE FIVE TWO
PATTERN AND R. S. B. SIXTY SIX
SEVEN OH PATTERN SO WE'LL BE
SUBSTITUTING THOSE AS
APPROPRIATE. MOVING ON THE
SENATOR ALLEN SP FOUR THREE
THREE CALIFORNIA COASTAL ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX THAT IS A
DO PASS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATE BILL FOUR THREE THREE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER FORTINO HI.
FOURTEEN II BATES NUMBERING.
BRADFORD OUR BRADFORD PA JONES.
JONES BY COME UNDER I COME.
LAYERED HI LAYERED HI MY CASKEY
HIGH MACKENZIE HI SIX ZERO.
THAT IS OUT SIX TO ZERO MOVING
TO SP FOUR FIVE NINE ALLEN ON
THE POLITICAL FOR REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR- THAT IS
A DO PASS WITH A ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE. SENATE BILL FOUR FIVE
NINE MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR FORTINO.
HI FORTINO FIVE BATES.
STRATFORD ALL RIGHT BRADFORD HI
JONESVILLE JONES NO LONGER HI
CAMARGO LAYERED. LAYERED HI
WHERE CASKEY HI KELSEY ARE.
PHOTOS FIVE TO ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT FIVE TO ONE MOVING ON SP
FOUR EIGHT THREE ON REMOVING
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS IT IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WITH
THAT MA'AM IT'S PER AUTHOR TO
EXTEND THE TIMELINE INSTITUTE
PHASES AND COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TO EXTEND CERTAIN COURT TIME
LINES WE ARE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR SP
THREE FOR THREE SO THAT BILL IS
OUT. FIVE TO TWO. MOVING ON SP
FIVE OH TWO I'M GREEN
CHEMISTRY- THIS IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND IT IS A ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL FIVE ZERO TWO
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER FORTINO HI FORTINO
FIVE BATES. BRADFORD R.
BRADFORD HI JONES NO JONES NO
LONGER HI FOLLOW HER HI LAYERED
PIE LAYERED ALL RIGHT WHAT
COUNTY HI KELSEY ARE. IT'S FIVE
TO ONE THAT FILLS OUT FIVE TO
ONE- MOVING ON TO S. B. SIX
ELEVEN ON INCOME TAX CREDITS
FOR MOTION PICTURE INDUSTRY
THAT IS A DO PASS AND IT WE'RE
pSUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FOR SB
SIXTY SIX SO THAT THAT WAS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO. MOVING ON TO
SENATOR ALLEN SP SIX TWENTY
EIGHT CALIFORNIA CREATIVE
WORKFORCE ACT. THAT IS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION AND WE ARE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FOR S. B.
THREE FORTY THREE SO THAT BILL
IS OUT FIVE TO TWO. MOVING ON
SB SIX SIX FOUR ON HOSPICE
LICENSE MORATORIUM IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FOR SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FOR S. B. THREE FOUR
THREE SO THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE
TWO TWO- WE'RE MOVING ON SB
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR CONCERT.
CONSERVATIVE THESE LEGAL
COUNSEL- THAT IS A DO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
STRIKE THE REPEAL OF FUNDING
CONTINGENCY LANGUAGE AND WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FOR SB SIXTY SIX. AND SO THAT
BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO
MOVING ON SB SEVEN FIVE TWO
ELECTIONS DISCLOSURE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FOR SP
THREE FOR THREE SO THAT BILL IS
OUT. ON A FIVE TO TWO VOTE
MOVING TO SENATOR ARCH ALETTA
SP TWO FOR LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES FIND PREVENTION- THAT
IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FOR
SB SIXTY SIX. THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN TO ZERO S. B. SIX TWO SIX
EIGHT SENATOR ARCHER LETTER ON
LOWER SAN GABRIEL RIVER
RECREATION AND PARKS DISTRICT.
IT IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
NUMBER SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FOR SB SIXTY SIX THAT BILL IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. MOVING ON
AS B. TWO SEVEN SEVENS SENATOR
ARCHULETA ON FIREWORKS SEIZURES
AND MANAGEMENT- THAT IS A DO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR
TO LIMIT APPLICATION. FEES TO
THE COST OF ADMINISTRATION AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE OF
SB SIXTY SIX THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO. SP SIX FOUR
THREE FUEL CELL EVEY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PRODUCTION
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENTS- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS A MAN PER
AUTHOR TO REMOVE THE WORKING
GROUP THAT BILL WE'RE
SUBSIDIZING THE ROLE OF SB
SIXTY SIX. THAT PHYLLIS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO. MOVE TO SENATOR
ATKINS THE PRO. SP ONE AND
CLOSE REESE C. LEVEL RISE-
WE'RE THERE IS TO DO PASS I'M
GONNA TAKE A ROLL CALL. THE
SENATE BILL ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
FORTINO HI FORTINO HI BATES.
BATES BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI
JONES NO JONES NO COMMAGER HI
CAMARGO A LAYERED HI LAYERED HI
MY CASKEY HI. KELSEY FIVE SIX
TO ONE. THAT BILL IS OUT SIX TO
ONE MOVING ON TO SENATOR ATKINS
SP NINE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
DUPLEX IN URBAN LOT SPLIT
APPROVALS. IT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
S. P. THREE FOUR THREE. THAT
BILL IS OUT FIVE TWO TWO. AT
THE CENTRE ATKINS SP FIVE
TWELVE SR SEVENTY FIVE AN SR
TWO EIGHTY TWO HIGHWAY
RELINQUISHMENT. THAT IS A DO
PASS AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL OF SB SIXTY SIX OF
THAT BILL IS OUT. SEVEN TWO
ZERO MOVING TO SENATOR BATES-
SP TWO FOR A. S. V. P. NEW
OFFENSES- THAT IS A DO PASS AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB SIXTY SIX AT APPLE
IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. A
SENATOR BATES SB SEVEN EIGHTEEN
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE SMALL
EMPLOYER GROUPS IT IS A DO PASS
AND WE'RE SUBSIDIZING THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX SO THAT BILL
IS OUT. SEVEN ZERO. MOVING TO
SENATOR BACKER SP SIXTY EIGHT
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION- THAT
RECOMMENDATION IS AMENDMENTS
PER AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES IN COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
REMOVE ELECTRIC SERVICES
RESPONSE TIME STANDARDS. THAT
BILL IS OUT- WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM THREE SP THREE
FOR THREE THAT PHYLLIS OUT.
FIVE TWO TWO- BECKER SP THREE
FIVE FIVE COURT FEES AND COSTS
WAIVERS- RECOMMENDATION AS
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO STRIKE
CERTAIN BENEFITS. REPLACE THE
USE OF SO WE REPLACE THE USE OF
MONTHLY INCOME WITH ANNUAL
INCOME AND MAKE OTHER. CHANGES
SO AS AMENDED WE'RE- THE ROLL
CALL FROM S. P. SIXTY. SO BILL
IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SP FIVE
BOTH. VOTING BALLOTS AND
SIGNATURE VERIFICATION- IT IS
THE MOTION IS WITH THE MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. AND WE'RE SUGGESTING
THE ROLE FROM SP THREE FOR
THREE SO THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE
TWO TWO. SP FIVE OH FOUR
ELECTIONS VOTER REGISTRATION IT
IS A DO PASS AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX- WHICH IS A UNANIMOUS
SEVEN. ZERO VOTE SO THAT THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE AFFORDS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO. S. B. FIVE
NINETY SIX GREENHOUSE GASES
CEMENT AND CONCRETE PRODUCTION
IT IS A DO PASS. AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SP THREE FOR THREE THAT BILL IS
OUT FIVE TO TWO. SP SIX FORTY
TRANSPORTATION FINANCING
JOINTLY PROPOSE PROJECTS IT IS
A MOTION WELL WITH AMENDMENTS
FOR AUTHOR TO DELETE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE LEAD
AGENCY PROPOSES A PROJECT THAT
IS JOINTLY FUNDED. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ADD A CO
AUTHOR FOR SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX THAT
BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. SP
SEVEN SIX SEVEN ON EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAMS- IT IS A
MOTION WITH AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO REMOVE THE
APPROPRIATION TO MAKE THE
PROGRAM CONTINGENT UPON IT
APPROPRIATIONS I'M GONNA TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON SB SEVEN SIX
SEVEN. SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER FORTINO NINE FORTINO
ALRIGHT BATES HI BATES HI
BRADFORD R. BRADFORD HI JONES
THOUGH. JONES NO LONGER HI
MARGARET BY LAYER BY LAYER HI
WE'RE CASKEY HI CASKEY HI SIX
TO ONE. THAT BILL IS OUT SIX TO
ONE. THAT WAS SP SEVEN SIX
SEVEN MOVING ON SB SEVEN SEVEN
ONE SALES AND USE TAX LAWS ZERO
EMISSIONS VEHICLE EXEMPTION. IT
IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION IN
A ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY ONE MOTIONS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER FORTINO HI FORTINO FIVE
BATES NO. BATES NO BRADFORD R.
BRADFORD BY JONES NO JONES
NARROW CAMARGO I. HAVE SOME
WATER HI LAYERED. I WORK. HI
CASKEY HI. HAVE FIVE TO THAT
FILLS OUT FIVE TWO. MOVING ON
TO BACKERS BILL SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE FELONY MURDER
RESENTENCING- THERE ARE AREAS
AND MOTIONED TO THE PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO EXPAND
RELIEF REQUIRE. THE COURTS
PROVIDE STATEMENT IF IT DENIES
RELIEF ALLOW THE ISSUE TO BE
RAISED IN A DIRECT APPEAL FOR
CASE. THAT IS NOT FINAL AND
MAKES OTHER CHANGES SO DOES OUR
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS INTO SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE. AT PHYLLIS OUT
FIVE TO. MOVING TO SENATOR
BRADFORD- SP TWO PEACE OFFICER
CERTIFICATION THE- THE MOTION
IS WITH AUTHRS AMENDMENTS TO
STRIKE THE PROPOSED CHANGES TO
THE MEANING. OF INTERFERENCE
WITH THE RIGHT UNDER THE BANE
ACT AND TO LIMIT THE WRONGFUL
DEATH CAUSE OF ACTION TO
CERTAIN CRIMES. THAT WE ARE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE SO AS AMENDED-
THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE TO TWO.
BRADFORD SP FIVE TO ONE ON DRUG
MANUFACTURERS VALUE BASED
ARRANGEMENTS IT IS A TO PASS. A
MOTION AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLL CALL OF SB SIXTY SIX
SO THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO. S. B. FIVE SIX SEVEN AN
AGGRAVATING FACTOR SENTENCING-
IT IS A MOTION WITH THE MEMONS
PER AUTHOR TOLD TO LIMIT WHEN
TRIALS NEED TO BE BIFURCATED.
AND THAT WE'RE SUBSIDIZING THE
ROLL CALL FROM SP THREE FOR
THREE SO THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE
TWO TWO. MOVING ON SP FIVE
EIGHTY SIX AND CRIMINAL FEES
COMMITTEE THAT THE MOTION IS
WITH COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO PICTURE ME AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS. THE STRIKE THE
REPEAL OF CERTAIN FEES AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO STRIKE.
THE REPEAL OF ADDITIONAL FEES
THAT BILL WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM S. B. THREE FOUR
THREE SO S. B. FIVE EIGHTY SIX
IS OUT FIVE TWO TWO. SP SIX OH
THREE AND CANNABIS LICENSING
DEFERRAL AND WAIVER FEE PROGRAM
TAX. CREDIT THEY ARE COMEDIAN
THEM MEANT TO MAKE IT
CONTINGENT IT UP. SO WITH A
MEMBER IT IS A RAW CALL. SENATE
BILL SIX OH THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTENT TINO HI
FORTINO I'D BATES. BRADFORD HI
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT JONES. COM
LOGGER HI COME ANDRADE LAYERED
LAYERED HI MY CASKET HI CASKEY
FIVE FIVE ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FIVE ZERO MOVING ON SB SEVEN
TEN PROSECUTORS CONFLICT OF
INTEREST THERE ARE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO SPECIFY WHEN THE
RECEIPT OF MONEY BENEFITS
CONSTITUENTS A CONFLICT
CONSTITUTES A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST WE ARE SUBSIDIZING THE
ROLL CALL OF SP THREE FOR THREE
SO THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE TO
TWO. SB SEVEN FOUR THREE ON
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS BROADBAND
ADDED ADOPTION IT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND WE'RE
SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FROM S.
P. SIXTY SIX AND SO THAT THAT
WAS OUT SEVENTY ZERO SB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN ON INSURANCE
TAXATION CREDIT CALIFORNIA
JUMPSTART ACT- THERE ARE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT
THE BILL CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION AND WE'RE SUBSIDY
IN THE ROLL CALL OF SB SIXTY
SIX THAT BILL IS OUT. SEVEN
ZERO MOVING ON TO CENTRE
BRADFORD'S FINAL BILL SB SEVEN
EIGHT EIGHT ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION RISK FACTORS THAT
IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AND
WE'RE GOING TO DO A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON SB SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR FORTINO
NINE FORTINO HI BATES ALL
RIGHT. BATES HI BRADFORD ALL
RIGHT. BRADFORD HI JONES. COM
LAGER. COME LONGER BY LAYERED
BY LATER HI MY CASKEY HI KELSEY
HI. SIX TWO ZERO S. B. SEVEN
EIGHT EIGHT IS OUT SIX TO ZERO
MOVING TO SENATOR KAPPA ZERO.
SB SIX LOWS OF LOCAL PLANNING
HOUSING COMMERCIAL ZONES IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AND
WE'RE GOING TO DO A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON SB SIX. SENATE BILL SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR FORTINO HI
FORTINO FIVE BATES NO. BATES NO
BRADFORD HI BRADFORD FIVE JONES
HI. JONES HI KAAM LONGER I HAVE
SOME WATER A LAYER BY LAYER ALL
RIGHT WHAT KIND OF SKI HI
KELSEY FIVE. SIX TO ONE. THE SP
SIX IS OUT SIX TO ONE. MOVING
ON SP TWENTY EIGHT RURAL
BROADBAND AND DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND IT IS WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FOR SB SIXTY SIX. SO S. B.
TWENTY EIGHT IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO. AS P. THREE SIX FIVE AND
MEDIC COW HE COULD CONSULT
SERVICES REIMBURSEMENT OF
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CLINICS AND RURAL HEALTH
CLINICS. IT IS A TO PASS A
MOTION AND WE ARE SUBSTITUTING
THE- VOTE FROM S. SIXTY SIX SO
SP THREE SIXTY FIVE IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO. SP THREE
SEVENTY ONE HEALTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY ADVISORY COMMITTEE
AND GRANT PROGRAM- THE MOTION
IS WITH A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
TED CO AUTHORS AND INCORPORATE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM S. P. SIXTY SIX. SO THE
BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO SP THREE
EIGHTY TWO ON RESTRAINING
ORDERS. THE MOTION IS WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO STRIKE
THE FIREARM RESTRAINING ORDER
PROVISION. AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX AND SO SP THREE
EIGHTY TWO IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO. SP THREE NINETY FIVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES PREVENTION
EDUCATION EXCISE. TAX
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES IT IS A
DEEP. RECOMMENDATION MO AND IT
IS A RAW CALL THE- SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY FIVE IN TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
FORTINO HI FORTUNE TINO OD
BATES. BRADFORD ALL RIGHT
BRADFORD HI JONES CALM WATER HI
FROM OTHER I'D LAYERED HI
LAYERED CASKEY HI CASKEY HI
FIVE. JON SNOW. JONES NOVARTIS
FIVE TO ONE THREE SP THREE
NINETY FIVE IS OUT FIVE TO ONE-
SP FOUR SEVENTY TWO SOCIAL
INNOVATION FINANCING PROGRAM
THEIR COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE SPECIFIED PROVISIONS
CONTINGENT ON FUNDING REQUIRE
THE USE OF THE SAME DEFINITION
OF RECIDIVISM AND CHANGE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COST RECOVERY
DISTRIBUTION SO WITH THAT
AMENDMENT I AM SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX SOS.
BEFORE SEVENTY TWO IS OUT SEVEN
TWO ZERO AS BEFORE NINETY
HOUSING ACQUISITION AND
REHABILITATION TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IT IS A DO PASS. A
MOTION AND I AM SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM S. P. SIXTY SIX
SP FOUR NINETY IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO SP FIVE THIRTY TWO HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION EXEMPTION TO
DO PASS MOTION AND I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX THAT BILL IS OUT
EIGHT FARM WORKER DISASTER
RELIEF PLANNING TASK FORCE
WHERE IS THE MOTION IS WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO CPAS
PACIFY TASK FORCE MEETING
FREQUENCY AUTHORIZE REMOTE
MEETINGS AND AD CO AUTHORS I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S.
SIXTY SIX. AS AMENDED SP FIVE
FIVE EIGHT IS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO
SB SIX TO FIVE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCING
INSTITUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM IS A
DO PASS MOTION AND I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX SO SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
IS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO SB SIX
SEVEN ZERO ON IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS WE HAVE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO REALIGN FELONY
OFFENSES AND TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION SO WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS I AM SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX AND
SO SP SIX SEVENTY IS OUT SEVEN.
ZERO LIVING TO SENATOR CORTESE
SP THIRTY SEVEN A HAZARDOUS
WASTE SITE CLEANUP AND SAFETY
ACT TO DO PASS MOTION AND I'M
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
S. P. SIXTY SIX RECIPES THIRTY
SEVEN IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO AS
B. TWO THIRTEEN WORKERS
COMPENSATION. HOSPITAL
EMPLOYEES IT IS A DEEP PASS- MO
AND I SUCH A THE ROLE CALL FROM
THREE FOR THREE SO I SPEAK TO
THIRTEEN IS OUT FIVE TO TWO. SP
THREE HUNDRED MURDER PUNISHMENT
WE HAVE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES SO WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS. WERE SUBSIDY
THE ROLE FROM S. B. THREE FOUR
THREE SO S. P. THREE HUNDRED IS
OUT FIVE TO TWO- SP THREE THREE
FIVE ON WORKERS COMPENSATION
LIABILITY. TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I AM
SUBSTITUTING THE MOBILE THE
ROLL CALL VOTE FROM THREE FOUR
THREE SP THREE FOR THREE. SO SP
THREE THREE FIVE IS OUT FIVE TO
TWO SP FOUR SIX ONE UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
A DO PASS I'M SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM SP THREE FOR THREE.
SO S. B. FOR SIXTY ONE IS OUT
FIVE TO TWO. SP SIX NINETY TWO
STATE PRIORITY AREAS LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENT. THAT IS A DO PASS
AND I'M SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX. SP SIX
NINETY WAS OUT SEVEN ZERO SB
SEVEN THIRTY NINE FOSSE INCOME
PILOT PROGRAM IS A DO PASS
MOTION AND WE'RE GONNA DO A
ROLL. CALL VOTE ON SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS O THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
FORTINO HI FORTINO HI BATES.
RADFORD HI BRADFORD HI JONES.
JONES MELLOW CALM WATER HI
KAMAGRA BUY LAYERED HI LAYERED
BY CAL SKI HI KANSKE HI. WE
HAVE FIVE TO ONE S. P. SEVEN
THIRTY NINE IS OUT FIVE TO ONE
SB SEVEN NINETY ONE CALIFORNIA
SURPLUS LAND UNIT. WE HAVE
AUTHORS MMS REQUIRE FUNDING
RECIPIENTS TO COMPLY WITH
SPECIFIED LABOR PROTECTIONS AND
SO WITH THAT AMENDMENT IT'S A
ROLL CALL THE- SENATE BILL
SEVEN NINETY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR FORTINO HI
FORTINO ALRIGHT BATES. READ I
BRADFORD HI JOHN. COM AUGER AND
FROM LAGER HI LAYERED HI THERE
HI AND WE'RE CASKEY HI MAKOWSKI
HI IT'S FIVE TO ZERO SB SEVEN
NINETY ONE IS OUT FIVE ZERO
MOVING TO SENATOR DOLLY AS B.
TWO OH SEVEN PHOTOVOLTAIC
RECYCLING ADVISORY GROUP THERE
ARE TOO MANY AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
IT CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION NUMBER
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S.
SIXTY SIX SIZE AMENDED SB TWO
OH SEVEN. IS APPROVED SEVEN TO
ZERO AS B. TWO OH EIGHT SIERRA
NEVADA CONSERVANCY- THAT IS A
DO PASS AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX SO
S. B. TWO OH EIGHT IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO MOVING TO SENATOR DODD SP
TWENTY STUDENT NUTRITION
ELIGIBILITY FOR CALFRESH
BENEFITS IT IS A DEEP PASS
MOTION OR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX SB TWENTY S.
OUT SEVENTY ZERO SB NINETY NINE
COMMUNITY ENERGY ENERGY
RESILIENCY ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IS A D. PASS MOTION AND
RECEPTION ROLE FROM SB SIXTY
SIX RECIPE NINETY NINE IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO SP ONE OH NINE
OFFICE OF WINE TECHNOLOGY
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT WE
HAVE COMMITTEE AMENDS TO ADD A
SUNSET DATE AS AMENDED WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB SIXTY SIX WHICH MAKES S. B.
ONE OH NINE MOVED UNANIMOUS
SEVEN ZERO OUT AS B. TWO
SIXTEEN CONTRACTORS MANDATORY
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE
COVERAGE THAT IS A DO PASS
MOTION AND WE ARE AGAIN
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. SO S. B. TWO SIXTEEN
PASSES. SEVEN TWO ZERO THREE
TWO TWO TWO WATER AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT
CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION AND WE'RE
SUBSIDIZING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SP THREE FOR THREE SO SP TWO
TWO TWO AS AMENDED IS OUT FIVE
TO TWO SP THREE THREE TO CIVIL
LIABILITY PRESCRIBED BURNS IT
IS IT DID PASS. A MOTION AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB. SIXTY SIX RESPITE
THREE THREE TWO WAS OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO. AS BEFORE FIVE ONE DAY
CAN RECYCLING PILE PROJECTS IT
IS IT PASS. RECOMMENDATION OR
MOTION AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX
ARRESTS BEFORE FIVE ONE PASSES
SEVENTY ZERO SB SEVEN ONE SEVEN
COMPLEX NEEDS PATIENT ACT. WE
HAVE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY FUTURE C. R. T. RATES
AND POLICIES TO MAKE RATE CUT
RESTORATIONS EFFECTIVE UPON A
FUTURE APPROPRIATION- THAT IS A
SUBSTITUTE ROLE CALL FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. SP SEVEN ONE SEVEN
MOVES ON A SEVEN ZERO VOTE. WE
HAVE DIED TO MANY GOVERNMENT
ORGANISATIONS SP EIGHT OH TWO
STATE DESIGNATED FARES
ALLOCATION OF SALES TAX. THAT
IS A DO PASS SUMMER
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. SP EIGHT TWENTY
YEARS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. SP
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT DISPOSAL OF
SURPLUS STATE PROPERTY IS A DO
PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX SO S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT IS OUT SEVEN. ZERO MOVING
TO SENATOR TO RISE OUT SP FIFTY
SIX MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY FOR
OVER SIXTY FIVE WITHOUT REGARD
IMMIGRATION STATUS SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION. WE'RE MAKING
AUTHORS IN THEM IS TO INCREASE
THE AGE FROM NINETEEN TO TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FIVE EXCUSE ME.
ELIMINATE STATE CONTRACT
OPTIONS AND ADD CO AUTHORS AND
WE'RE ADDING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO REDUCE THE AGE
FROM SIXTY FIVE TO SIXTY. AND
SO WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM S. B. THREE FOUR THREE
THAT BILL WAS. APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF FIVE TO TWO- SOURCE TO
THE THREE FOUR SO THAT IS OUT
FIVE TO TWO. SP SIXTY TWO.
EMPLOYMENT GARMENT
MANUFACTURING THAT IS A DO PASS
FIRST- DO PASS WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE SO THAT BILL IS
APPROVED FIVE TO TWO. ESPYS TWO
SEVENTY PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT LABOR
RELATIONS EMPLOYEE INFORMATION
IS IT TO PASS RECOMMENDED
MOTION AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SP THREE FOR
THREE SO THAT BILL IS ALPHA
FIVE TWO TWO. SP THREE TWENTY
ONE EMPLOYMENT SAFETY STANDARDS
HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC SERVICES IT
IS A DO PASS MOTION WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S.
B. THREE FOUR THREE. SP THREE
TWENTY ONE IS OUT FIVE TO TWO
SP THREE THIRTY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS A DO PASS A MOTION
AND RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE SO THAT BILL IS
OUT FIVE TO TWO. SP FOUR EIGHT
ONE SENTENCING SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT ELIGIBILITY
TO INDIVIDUALS TWENTY FIVE AND
UNER AT THE TIME OF THE
OFFENCE REMOVE THE PRESUMPTION.
ALLOW THE COURTS TO STRIKE A
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE ONLY IF IT
RESULTS IN A PAROLE HEARING AND
MAKES OTHER CHANGES. WITH THAT
AUTHOR'S AMENDMENT WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE AND SO AS
BEFORE A ONE IS OUT FIVE TO
TWO. SP SIX THIRTY NINE MINIMUM
WAGES PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES- THERE ARE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO DESIGNATE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AS THE LEAD AGENCY
AND TO ADD A CO AUTHOR. SO WITH
THAT AMENDMENT WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE SO S. B. SIX
THIRTY NINE IS OUT FIVE TO-
ALSO FROM SENATOR ROGER SP SIX
SEVEN FOR PUBLIC CONTRACTS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
TRANSPORTATION RELATED
CONTRACTS WE HAVE AUTHORS MMS
DATA CO AUTHOR MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND TO DESIGNATE THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AS THE LEAD AGENCY.
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SP. THREE FOUR THREE SIX
THREE SIX SEVEN FOUR IS OUT
FIVE TO TWO. SB SEVEN THIRTY
ONE CRIMINAL RECORDS RELIEF- WE
HAVE A COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
EXCLUDE CERTAIN FELONIES FROM
AUTOMATIC RELIEF DELAY
AUTOMATIC. CHIN AND STRIKE THE
RESTRICTION ON ACCESS TO
CLEARED RECORDS AND LIMIT
RETROACTIVITY- WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND WE ARE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S.
B. THREE FOUR THREE. SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE IS OUT AS AMENDED
FIVE TO TWO. MOVING TO SENATOR
EGGMAN SP TWO FOR- INCOME TAX
CREDITS FOR FOOD BANKS THAT IS
A DO PASS AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX SO. AS B. TWO FORTY
IS OUT SEVEN ZERO AS B. TWO
FOUR SEVEN RARE DISEASE
ADVISORY COUNCIL. WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR'S MMS DELETE THE RARE
DISEASE I'M THE BEST PERSON AND
WITH THAT AMENDED WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX SO I SPEAK TO FOUR
SEVEN IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. SP
THREE SIXTEEN ON MEDICARE
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS AND RURAL HEALTH
CLINICS. VISIT DO PASS MOTION
AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM S. P. SIXTY SIX AND SO
THAT BILL THREE SIXTEEN SOUTH
SEVENTY ZERO. SP THREE TWENTY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS AND POSSESSION OF A
FIREARM IS A D. PASS MOTION AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX. THAT BILL IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. SP THREE
EIGHT ZERO ON END OF LIFE
OPTIONS IT IS A DO PASS. AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM S. B. THREE FOUR THREE SO
SP THREE EIGHTY IS OUT FIVE TO
TWO. S. BEFORE SIXTY FIVE
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS YEP AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO STRIKE SPECIFIED
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL RETAIN
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS SO AS
AMENDED WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX. THAT'S
A RECIPE FOR SIX FIVE IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO SP FIVE OH SEVEN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT. TO DO
PASS MOTION AND RECEPTION THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX SIXTY
FIVE OH SEVEN IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO. S. B. SIX NINE NINE
SCHOOL CLIMATE INDICATORS AND
SURVEYS IT IS A DEEP PASS. A
MOTION AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM S. B. THREE FOUR
THREE WHICH MEANS THE BILL IS
AB ON A FIVE TO TWO. VOTE
PROTECTS SIX NINE NINE. WE HAVE.
THANKS H. TURNING PRO WE GO TO
THAT CONCLUDES AND MOVING TO
SENATOR GLAZER SP NINE WIND
GROW TO ROOM THEY DO PASS
MOTION AND RECEPTION TO THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX JUST BE
NINETEEN IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO
S. B. TWENTY TWO ON SCHOOL
FACILITIES EDUCATION BOND ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO WE
HAVE A COMMITTEEMEMBER SAID
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR MENTA HEALTH AND WELLNESS
CENTRES AND STADIUM LIGHTS
AUTHORIZE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR NEW MEDICAL SCHOOL PROGRAM
AND ADD A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR-
WE ARE DOING A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON SB TWENTY TWO. SENATE BILL
TWENTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER FORTINO HI FORTINO
FIVE BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD
HI JONES NO JONES NO COM LAGER
HI CAMARGO. LAYER HI LAYERED-
AND WHAT KIND OF SKIN. HI KATHY
R. SIX TO ONE- SP TWENTY TWO IS
OUT SIX TO ONE. AS BEFORE FOUR
SIX FACTUAL INNOCENCE WE HAVE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO EXTEND
PROCESSING TIME TO NINETY DAYS.
RECEPTIVE IN THE ROLL CALL FROM-SB SIXTY SIX SO AS AMENDED THAT.
BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO- SP
FIVE FORCE CAL VETERINARIAN.
TEAM PROGRAMS THEY DO PASS
MOTION AMBER SUBZERO FROM SB.
SIXTY SIX FIFTY FIVE FOR SEVEN
IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SP FIVE
NINE THREE NINE CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOL AUDITS. WE HAVE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO ESTABLISH
A NEW AUDIT REVIEW AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND MAKE
OTHER CLARIFYING CHANGES.
WITHOUT AMENDMENT- WE'RE
SUBSIDY THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY
SIX AND SO S. B. FIVE NINETY
THREE IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SB
SIX EIGHT SIX CAMPAIGN
DISCLOSURE LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANIES. IS A DO PASS MOTION
AND WE'RE WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SP THREE FOR
THREE. SB SIX EIGHT SIXES OUT
FIVE TO TWO SB SEVEN FOUR FOR
COMMUNICABLE COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE RESPIRATORY DISEASE
INFORMATION WE HAVE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
AS AMENDED WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX. AND
SO AS B. SEVEN FOUR FOUR IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO SB SEVEN FOUR NINE
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM OVERSIGHT
COUNTY REPORTING. WE HAVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO MAKE IT
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
AS AMENDED WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX. IS
THAT BILL IS OUT ON A SEVEN
ZERO VOTE SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
C. S. U. CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM- IT IS A DO PASS. AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX OR SB SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE IS OUT SEVEN ZERO.
SB SEVEN NINETY TWO SALES AND
USE TAX RELATES RETAILERS
REPORTING WE HAVE A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE SO SB SEVEN
NINETY TWO AS AMENDED IS OUT.
TWO TWO SB SEVEN NINE NINE
CARNEGIE STATE VEHICULAR
RECREATION AREA ALAMEDA TEST
THEIR EXPANSION AREA. IT IS A
DO PASS AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SP THREE FOR
THREE S. B. SEVEN NINE NINE IS
OUT FIVE TO TWO. SP EIGHT OH
FOUR FORESTRY. CORPS PROGRAM
FORMALLY IN. IN WE HAVE ALL MM
A CLASS THAT THE TRAINING SO
WOULD SERVE FORMALLY.
INDIVIDUALS THE DIRECTOR OF
THIS CAN BE USED DEPARTMENT. SO
AS AMENDED WERE SUBSTANTIVE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX AND SO
SP EIGHT OH FOUR IS OUT SEVEN
TWO ZERO. MOVING TO SENATOR
GONZALES SP FOUR CALIFORNIA
ADVANCE SERVICES FIND IF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO CAP THE
ANNUAL SURCHARGE REVENUE FOR
THE- DEAF AND DISABLED
TELEPHONE PROGRAM. AS AMENDED
WERE SECTION IN THE ROLE FROM
SP THREE FOR THREE. SO S.
BEFORE IS OUT FIVE TWO TO. S.
B. TWO FOUR FIVE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE ABORTION SERVICES COST
SHARING IS A DO PASS MOTION AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SP THREE FOR THREE. AND SO
S. B. TWO FOUR FIVE SOUTH FIVE
TO TWO. SP THREE THREE EIGHT
PORT. THE MOTOR CARRIERS
SEVERAL LIABILITY. IS A DO PASS
MOTION AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING.
THE ROLL CALL FROM S. B. THREE
FOUR THREE SO S. P. THREE THREE
EIGHT. IS OUT FIVE TO TWO SP
FOUR FIVE TO IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE AFFAIRS AGENCY WE HAVE
A COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
THE AGENCY CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION. SO AS AMENDED
WERE SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE AND SO S.
BEFORE FIVE TWO WAS OUT FIVE TO
TWO. SB SIX OH SIX WORKPLACE
SAFETY VIOLATIONS OF STATUTES
EMPLOYER RETALIATION WE HAVE
AUTHORS MMS STRIKE THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION OF
RETALIATION. AND SO AS AMENDED
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE SO S. B. SIX OH
SEX IS OUT FIVE TO TWO. SB SIX
SEVEN ONE CLEAN SLATE CAR CLEAR
CLEAN FREIGHT CARTER EFFICIENCY
PROGRAM. VISIT DO PASS MOTION
AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM S. P. SIXTY SIX. SP
SIX SEVEN ONE IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX
ALTERNATIVE AND RENEWABLE FUEL
AND VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM
IS A DO PASS. MOTION AND WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A ROLL CALL AND S.
B. SEVEN TWENTY SIX SENATE BILL
SEVEN TWENTY SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTENT TINA HI. THIS
GIVES ME FORTINO FIVE BATES NO
BREAKS NO BRADFORD PARK
BRADFORD HI JONES NO. NO COM
LOGGER LAST HI CAMARGO LAYERED
HI THERE HI CASKEY HI. CASKEY I.
FIVE TO TWO. SO S. B. SEVEN TWO
SIX IS A FIVE TO ASK SEVEN SIX
IS A DO. A MOTION AND WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A ROLL CALL IN SEVEN
SEVEN SIX. SENATE BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
FORTINO HI FORTINO FIVE BATES
ALL RIGHT. BATES FIVE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI JONES HI. SKI JONES
NOW JOBS NO PHONES NO. COM
LARGER HI FROM OUR BY LAYERED
HI LAYERED HI MACKENZIE HI
CASKEY I SIX TWO ONE PRESS P.
SEVENTY SIX IS OUT TO ONE.
MOVING TO SEE GRAHAM S. THIRTY
NINE FOR CLAIMS IN TO THE IF
YOU PAY. WE'RE GONNA SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLE FROM S. SIX SIX SO SP
THIRTY NINE IS A SEVEN ZERO B.
TWO SO IDEA TRAILER VISIT DO
PASS WE'RE GONNA SEE THE ROLL
CALL FROM S. B. SIXTY. SO TO
SPEAK EIGHT SEVEN OUT DAYS SP
THREE FOR A VETERANS HOME
BECAUSE REVIEW IT IS A PASS
MOTION NUMBER SUB TO THE ROLE
FROM S. B. SIXTIES. THE SPEECH
FOR A THREE FOUR EIGHT IS OUT
SO TWO ZERO MOVING TO SAN HURTS
SP TWO SIXTY. BAIL WE HAVE
AUTHORS IN THEM IS TO EXCLUDE
ADDITION CRIMES FROM ZERO UP
FROM ZERO DOLLAR BAIL REQUIRE
THE SETTING BALLOCH TO THIS FOR
NEW CHAR WHEN A CURRENT CHARGES
PENDING AND REQUIRE THE COURT
TO CONSIDER NON FINANCIAL
RELEASE CONDITIONS AND MAKE AN
ABILITY TO PAY DETERMINATION IF.
BAIL IS. IN UPON THEM ONCE.
ALL
RIGHT SO AS AMENDED- S. B. TWO
SIX TWO IS OUT WE'RE GONNA
SUBSIDY THE ROLE FROM SP THREE
FOR THREE SO THAT IS A FIVE TWO
TWO- THE TOP FIVE TO TWO. S. B.
THREE FOUR FOUR HOMELESS
SHELTER GRANTS PETS AND
VETERINARY SERVICES- THAT IS
THAT WE HAVE AUTHORS A MEMBER
SAID CO AUTHOR CEMENT TO MAKE
CONTINUED UPON APPROPRIATION
AND IT IS OUT FOR SUBZERO FROM
SB SIXTY SIX SO IT'S OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO THAT'S BEFORE FOR
PERSONAL INCOME TAX EXCLUSION
FROM GROSS INCOME. ALL
EDUCATION AWARD PROGRAM- IT IS
MM IT'S PER AUTHOR TO ADD CO
AUTHORS AND SO WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE AS
AMENDED HONEST PIECE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX SIXTY FOUR FOR FOUR
IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO S. BEFORE
FIVE ZERO FIRE PROTECTION
FUNDING WORKING GROUP- IT IS A
DO PASS AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX.
THAT'S A RECIPE FOR FIVE OH IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SP FIVE FIVE
TO DROUGHT PLANNING IN SMALL
WATER SUPPLIERS WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO STREAMLINE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND
RECEPTION ROLE FROM S. P. SIXTY
SIX SP FIVE FIVE TWO IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO SB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT DENSITY BONUS LAW
PURCHASE FOR SALE UNITS BY
NONPROFIT HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS
TO DO PASS. A MOTION AND
RECEPTION IN THE ROLE FROM S.
B. SIXTY SIX SIXTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT IS OUT. SEVEN TWO ZERO.
HAVING TO SET WASTE AS TO SO.
CORRECT HAD PRO. WE HAVE A
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS MAKE THE
BILL CONTINGENT ON FUNDING AND
WE'RE SUBZERO FROM SB SIXTY SIX
SIXTY FOUR SIXTEEN IS OUT SEVEN
TWO ZERO. SP FIVE EIGHT ZERO.
IS A CALTRANS ASPHALT RECYCLING
PLASTIC STUDY AND
SPECIFICATIONS. AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO SIMPLIFY OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL WORKLOAD FOR
SUBSIDY IN THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. AND SO SP FIVE EIGHT
ZERO IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. SP
FIVE EIGHTY NINE ALTERNATIVE
VEHICLES AND VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A DO PASS
MOTION AND RECEPTION ROLE FROM
S. P. SIXTY SIX. SP FIVE EIGHTY
NINE IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SB
SIX TO FOUR ENVIRONMENTAL
EQUITY IN OUTDOOR ACCESS ACT.
TO DO PASS MOTION AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX SP SIX TO FORCE OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO. SP SIX EIGHT
FOUR CALIFORNIA BORDER
COMMISSION TO DO PASS MOTION
NUMBER SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. SO SP SIX EIGHT FOUR
IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SB SIX
EIGHT SEVEN EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TRAUMA KITS TO DO PASS MOTION
OR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
SB SIXTY SIX. WEST B. SIX EIGHT
SEVEN IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SB
SEVEN OH FIVE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES
WORKING GROUP. IT IS A DO PASS
MOTION AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX SB
SEVEN OH FIVE IS OUT. SEVEN TWO
ZERO MOVING TO SENATOR TAYO.
CAN S. B. FORTY BY SENATOR TODD
I WANT HELP FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE CALIFORNIA. MEDICINE
SCHOLARS PROGRAM WE HAVE A
pCONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
I'M GONNA TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON SB FORTY. SENATE BILL FORTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER FOURTEEN NOW. HI FORTINO
FIVE STATES RIGHT EIGHT FIVE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI JONES NO
JON NO LONGER I WHO COME UNDER
HI THERE HI LAYERED BY ACCOUNTS.
HI CASKEY BY SIXTY. S. FORTY IS
OUT SIX ONE WE GOT S. SIX ONE
WORK TRAINING PROGRAMS SUPPORT
OF SERVICES. WE HAVE- AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE DEFINITIONAL
CHANGES AND PROVIDE DETAIL ON
GRANT FUNDING AWARD CRITERIA
WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON SB SIXTY ONE AS AMENDED.
SENATE BILL SIXTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
FORTINO HI FORTINO FIVE BATES
ALL RIGHT. BATES HI BRADFORD R.
BRADFORD HI JONES NO JONES NO
CALM WATER I A LAWYER BY. ALL
RIGHT LATER ON OKAY. HI KELSEY
ARE. SIX TWO. SB SIXTY IS OUT
SIX TO ONE S. ONE AWAY STATE
HIGHWAY HEALTHY FOOD ACCESS
POLICY. OF AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY DSS AS THE LEAD ON
THE REPORT. AND WE'RE GONNA
ROLL CALL VOTE ON SB ONE AWAIT.
SENATE BILL ONE ZERO EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
FORTINO HI FORTINO. FIVE BATES.
BRADFORD OUR BRADFORD HI JOE.
NO JONES. COM LAGER HI COM BUY
LAYERED ALL RIGHT LATER HI WHAT.
HI CASKEY FIVE THAT'S- FIVE TO
ONE. THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE TO
ONE IF ONE AWAIT A MOVIE I THIS
BECAUSE NINE THREE AND MARGARET
CHILDREN CHILD AND DEVELOPMENT
APPROACH. THAT OFFER AMENDMENTS
TO IN OTHER PROGRAMS AND AS
AMENDED RECEPTION THE ROLE S.
B. C. SO. AND SO AS WE NINE
THREE IS OUT TO SP OKAY MULTI
PAY PAYMENT COLLABORATIVE WE
HAVE AUTHORS AND TO MAKE
CONTENT UPON- OR SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM B. C. SIX. SO AS
AMENDED AS BEFORE- TO. PASSES
SO ZERO S. BEEF TWENTY
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE TO
EXPERIENCE. TO DO MOTION IN
RECEPTION IN THE ROLE OF S. B.
C. SIX JUST BEFORE TWENTY
EIGHT. SEVEN DOES S. FOR THREE
I. BY ALSO AND- INFECTIOUS
DISEASE FUNDS WE HAVE OFF MMS
REMOVE THE GENERAL FOR
APPROPRIATIONS AS A MAN WERE
SUBS TO THE ROLE FROM A SPEECH.
SO SOURCE BEFORE THREE. SEVEN
ZERO SP FOUR SIX FOUR K. FOOD
ASSIST PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY
WITHOUT REGARD IMMIGRATION
STATUS. WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO INCLUDE TECHNICAL
REVISIONS DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
TO MAKE CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION. AS FAR AS
AMENDED RECEPTION THE ROLE FOR
SP THREE FOR THREE AND TO THAT
BILL WAS OUT FIVE TO TWO. SP
FOUR NINE TWO MATERNAL HEALTH
PREGNANCY RELATED DEATH DATA TO
DO PASS MOTION AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX OF US BEFORE NINETY
TWO PASSES. SEVENTY TWO SP FIVE
NOT FIVE NINE SP FIVE FIVE NINE
COASTAL CONVEYANCE CAPACITY
RESTORATION FUNDS. AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND IT CO AUTHORS AND
WE HAVE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
MAKE IT CONTINGENT UPON A
FEDERALLY COST SHARE. READY TO
ROLL CALL VOTE. ON SP FIVE FIVE
NINE. STEVE THE SENATE BILL
FIVE FIVE NINE EMOTIONS PASSES
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PARK. I FOR ON BABY
RIGHT. BAITS ARE BRADFORD PARK
TRANSFERRED BYJONES I. JOE
FIVE COM LONGER HI. KAMAGRA
LAYERED ON. THERE HI. MIKE
OSCAR NO CASKEY NOW. SIXTY ONE
SP FIVE FIVE NINE IS A SIX ONE
AS PEACE OWNER CAL AND TRAINING
IMPROVED PROGRAM WE HAVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO IT CAN
UPON A PROBE SO AMENDED
RECEPTION ROLE FOR S. B. C. SIX
SP SIX ON IS THAT SEVEN ZERO AS
SIX FOUR EIGHT AND RICH HERE AT
ALL ROSE FOR PILOT ON SIR. AT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT
UPON AN APPROPRIATE SO AS
AMENDED WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
RALPH MUST BE SIXTY SIX SAYS B.
SIX FOUR EIGHT IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO MOVING TO SENATOR JONES AS
B. TWO TWO SEVEN HOUGH HIGHWAY
VEHICLES WE HAVE A MEMBER'S
PAROTID TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION TO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE AND REQUIRE- H. B.
COMPETITION STICKER AS A
CONDITION FOR USE ON PUBLIC
LANDS SO AS AMENDED WERE
SUBSTITUTE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY
SIX. AND SIXTY TWO TWO SEVEN IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SP THREE
FIVE EIGHT ON PROPERTY CRIMES
IT IS A DEEP PASS MORE
SUBSTANTIVE MORAL COFFER MUST
BE SIXTY SIX SO- SP THREE FIVE
EIGHT IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO S.
BEFORE SEVENTY ANNUAL COMBINE
HUNTING AND FISHING LICENSE IT
IS A DO PASS SUMMER
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S.
B. SIXTY SIX OF US BEFORE
SEVENTIES OUT SEVENTY ZERO SP
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT JUVENILES
ELECTRONIC CARE PORTAL HEALTH
INFORMATION SUMMARY
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS WE
HAVE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
EXTEND TIMELINES FOR PH ENDS.
TO INPUT THE FOSTER YOUTH
MEDICAL DATA FROM THREE TO FIVE
YEARS AND WE HAVE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
SIZE AMENDED WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLL CALL FROM S. B. SIX
SIX SIX SO SP FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO SENATOR
COM LAGER SP SIX SEVEN NINE LA
COUNTY AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
HAVE AUTHORS MMS TO SPECIFY
BOARD MEMBERSHIP AUTHORIZED THE
AGENCY TO IMPOSE TAXES ISSUE
BONDS AND ALLOCATE REVENUES
ACCORDING TO GEOGRAPHIC
SCHEDULE. AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES SO AS AMENDED SP SIX
SEVEN NINE WE'RE SUBSTITUTING.
THE ROLL CALL FROM S. B. THREE
FOUR THREE S. AS AMENDED SPC
SEVEN NINE. PASSES FOR TO TWO.
MOVING THIS LEAHY AS THREE
NINETY. EDT COP. PLAN WE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO ADD A
COUPLE SO AS A- WE'RE SO THE
RAW FROM SP SIXTY. SO SP THREE.
IS PAST SAID TO ZERO SP FOUR
EIGHTEEN SEA LEVEL RISE
PLANNING DATABASE IT IS A DEEP
PASS. MOTION OR SUBSTANTIVE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX SO S.
BEFORE EIGHTEEN PASSES SEVEN
TWO ZERO S. B. FOR THIRTY EIGHT
REDEVELOPMENT ENFORCEABLE
OBLIGATION CITY OF ASKED. COULD
AT TASKER DARROW. A TOUGH WORD
TO SAY IF YOU'RE NOT FROM.
ATASCADERO IT IS A DEEP PASS
MOTIONS AND WE ARE ACCEPTING
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX SO
THAT BILL THAT'S BEFORE THIRTY
IS OUT OF SEVEN TO ZERO. AS
BEFORE FIVE SIX FIRE PROPRIETOR
PREVENTION LONG TERM FOREST
MANAGEMENT PLANS THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE TRACKING
AND REPORTING OF FORAGE
TREATMENT DATA. AND THAT. HAS
AMENDED RECEPTION ROVER MUST BE
SIXTY SIX JUST BEFORE FIVE SIX.
IS OUT OF SEVEN TO ZERO AS
AMENDED AS BEFORE NINETY SIX
FLOOD CONTROL. BUT I HAVE. A
HERO. RIVER AND THAT IS IT I DO
PASS. AND WE HAVE NO MA'AM AND
SO IS STEPS TO THE ROLE FOR S.
B. C. SO TO SPEAK FOR NINE SIX
IS OUT SEVENTY SP FIVE A- OF.
SIR SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM.
WE HAVE COME MEMBERS TO MAKE IT
CONTAIN UPON A- RISING WHERE
SUBSIDY THE ROLE FOR S. B. C.
SIX. SP FIVE EIGHTEEN IS OUT
SEVEN TO ZERO FIVE FOR FOUR
CANNABIS TESTING. WE HAVE TOO
MANY AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
STANDARD TESTING METHODS AND
AUTHORIZED APPEAR TO CONTRACT
WITH A REFERENCE LAB- SO AS
AMENDED RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM
SB SIXTY SIX SP FIVE FOUR FOUR.
IS OUT. SEVEN TWO ZERO SB SIX
OH TWO REVIEW OF CONSERVATIVE
SHIPS IT IS A DEEP PASS MOTION
OR SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. SO SB SIX OH TWO IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO MOVING TO
SENATOR LEYVA AS P. FIFTY THREE
UNSOLICITED IMAGES WE HAVE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO MAKE A
FIRST TIME CRIMINAL VIOLATION
BY MINORS A WARNING. AND WITH
THAT AMENDMENT SB. SIXTY SIX
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE- ROW
CALL FROM A SIX SIX SO S. FIFTY
IS OUT. SEVEN ZERO SPC FOUR ON
MOBILE HOME PARK CODE. THAT
OFFERS A MEMBERSHIP. SPECIFY
DISCLOSURE WAS CERTAIN FINAL WE
HAVE TO MEMBER TO REDUCE THE
TIME. SECURING SENT DATA
REPLACE WRIST. ON ADDICTION
CASES WITH THE BILL OF A
TENTATIVE A SPECIFIED. AS
AMENDED RECEPTION TO THE ROLE
FROM SP THREE FOR THREE SB
SIXTY FOURS OUT FIVE TO TWO. AS
B. TWO OH FIVE SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EMPLOYEE PAID
LEAVE. THAT IS A DO PASS AND
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE SO THAT THAT
WAS OUT FIVE TO TWO. SP TWO
FIFTEEN DNA EVIDENCE WE HAVE
AUTHORS ARE MEMBERS TO CHANGE
ANONYMOUS ACCESS TO PRIVATE AND
SECURE ACCESS AND A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT AT A CO AUTHOR. SO AS
AMENDED WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FROM S. SIXTY SIX. S.
P. TWO FIFTEEN IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO SP TWO TWO A POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR FOSTER YOUTH. WE
HAVE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND A
COMMITTEE MEMBER TARA CO
AUTHOR. AND AS AMENDED B. TWO
X. EMAIL WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE MUST BE SIXTY SIX SO AS
AMENDED SB TWO TWO EIGHT IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO. AS B. TWO FOUR SIX
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
REIMBURSEMENT RATES A VISIT TO
PASS. AND WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE
ROLE FROM S. P. SIXTY SIX
RISER- DO PASS AS B. TWO FOUR
SIXES OUT SEVEN TO ZERO. THAT'S
B. TWO SEVEN EIGHT PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT SYSTEMS
THIS ABOUT COMPENSATION BENEFIT
CHESSMEN. VISIT TO PASS A
MOTION I'M GONNA TAKE A ROLL
CALL AND SP TWO SEVENTY EIGHT.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER FORTINO.
FIVE FORTINO. ALL RIGHTS AND-
BATES. SENATOR BRADFORD OUR-
PREP ALL EYES AND- JONES HI
JONES HI COM. HI CAMARGO BISON
LAYERED. HI EARLIER I ONCE IN A
WHILE COUNTY HI MAKOWSKI FIVE.
THAT IS SIXTY. S. B. TWO C.
EIGHT EIGHT OUT SO TO. MOVIE ON
S. TWO NINE NINE. COME USE OF
BY THE FOR OFFICE WE HAVE ALL
MM WHICH- DEATH CLAIM IF THE-
PERSON PERSON. KILLED ANOTHER
DURING THE INVOLVED IN A CRIME
AND WE THEM THAT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS EXCLUDE DEATH. IF THE
DATES PER BECAUSE ANOTHER PER
HERE BOUGHT SERIOUS BODY LEE
INJURY. SO I A MENTOR WE'RE
GONNA SEE. THE ROLE COUGH S. B.
TH FOURTH. AND SO AS TWO NINE
NINE IS OUT FIVE TO TWO. SP
THREE NINE COLLEGE. GRANT
PROGRAM WE HAVE AUTHORS MMS
MAKE TECH CHANGES AND ADD CO
AUTHORS AND WE HAVE A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE THE
APPROPRIATION AND MAKE THE
PROGRAM CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION. VIDEO ROLL CALL
AND SP THREE OH NINE AS
AMENDED. SENATE BILL THREE ZERO
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER FORTINO NINE FORTINO. HI
BATES. BRADFORD EFFORT BY JONES
JONES NO COM LOG. COMMA BUY
CENTER LAYER LATER HIGH
INSANITY WORKOUTS HI- WHAT DOES
THE THAT FIVE TO SO BE THREE OH
NINE IS OUT FIVE TO AS THREE
TWO AND MEDIA AND HEAVY DO
FLEET ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
EMISSION VEHICLE HAVE AUTHORS
IN IN THE DEATH OF COMMUNITIES
AND REMOVE PERCENT OF TIME A
VEHICLE STOP. IN AN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY GOING TO ROLL CALL
AND SP THREE SEVEN TWO SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTY TWO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
FORTINO HI FORTINO FIVE BATES
HI BAYSIDE BRADFORD BRADFORD BY
SENATOR JONES NOPE JONES NO
CALM WATER HI- LONGER HI
LAYERED HI LAYERED HI I CAN SKI
HI CASKEY HI SIX ONE THAT'S
THREE SEVENTY WITHOUT SIX ONE
SP FIVE TO THREE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CONTRACEPTIVES. THERE
IT IS A DO PASS OVER SEVENTEEN
THE ROLE FROM SP THREE FOUR
THREE SIX THREE FIVE TWO THREE
IS OUT FIVE TO TWO S. B. SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN LABOR RELATED
LIABILITIES DIRECT DIRECT
CONTRACTORS TO DO PASS MOTION
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM SP THREE FOR THREE SB
SEVEN TWO SEVEN IS OUT FIVE TO
TWO MOVING TO SENATOR LEMANIS
FORTY SEVEN HAZARDOUS AND IDLE
DESERTED WELLS IT IS A DO PASS
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM THREE FOR S. B. THREE
FOUR THREE. SIX B. FORTY SEVEN
IS OUT FIVE TO TWO SP FIFTY
CALIFORNIA EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE PROGRAM WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW
REIMBURSEMENT SPACE CENTER
ROMAN TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO REMOVE THE OPTION TO PROVIDE
WRAP AROUND SERVICES FOR
KINDERGARTEN ANTI CASE STUDENTS
AND AS AMENDED RECEPTION THE
ROLE FROM S. B. SIXTY SIX SP
FIFTY S. OUT SEVENTY ZERO SP
TWO NINE THREE MEDIC COW MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES EARLY. EARLY P.
HEARING PERIOD TO PERIOD YEAH
I'M JUST GONNA SAY SCREENING
DIAGNOSTIC AND TREATMENT
PROGRAMS AUTHOR'S AMENDMENTS
SAID CO AUTHOR SUMMIT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO ADD A PRINCIPAL
CO AUTHOR- AND SO AS AMENDED.
ROLE FROM BE SICK SIX. SIXTY
TWO NOW THREE S. SAID IS. SP
TWO NINE CO ENFORCD OFFICERS.
STANDARDS WE HAVE TO MEDIUM TO
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES. AND AS
AMENDED WERE SO ROLE OF S. B.
SIX SO AS TWO NINE SIX IS OUT
IS YOUR SPEECH SIX. HEALTH CARE
COVER TO DUCK AND OF POCKET
EXPENSE IS TO DO. MOTION WAS
THE ROLE FROM S. THREE FOR
THREE. SP THREE SIX EIGHT IS
OUR- OF. FIVE TWO. THAT'S
BEFORE NINE TWO DEPOSITS FOR.
ACCOUNT TO DO PASS. SO ROLE S.
B. C. SO. AND SO BEFORE SEVEN
OUT TWO ZERO SP FIVE THREE FIVE
BY- TESTING. WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR'S SICKLER PRIOR ON
THURSDAY REQUIRED ENTIRE ACCESS
TO CLINICAL TRIALS SO AMENDED
RECEPTION RALPH S. B. C. SIX.
SP FIVE THREE FIVE IS SO TO
ZERO. SP FIVE FOUR TWO MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS SALES AND TAX VEHICLE
LICENSING FEE. OF AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE PERIOD
OF SALES TAX EXEMPTION AND
CLARIFY ELIGIBILITY FOR H. V.
I. P. RECEIPT RECEIPT
RECIPIENTS. IF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO STRIKE THE BLF F. B.
L. F. PROVISION. AND AS AMENDED
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX SP FIVE FOUR
TWO MOOSE SEVEN TWO ZERO. SP
FIVE FOUR THREE STATE. AGENCY
NONPROFIT LIAISON. WE HAVE.
AUTHORS IN THEM TO SPUR.
CORRECT HERE FOR AGENCY. TO
DESIGNATE A LI A FOR AN
EXEMPTION OF DO FOR D. O. J.
AND REMOVE COBIZ NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS. AND SO AS AMENDED
IT IS PERCEPTION ROLL FROM SB
SIXTY SIX SP FIVE FOUR THREE IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. AS B. SEVEN
OH TWO THE MINOTAUR LAPOINTE
IT'S WORKING GROUP. WE HAVE AN
OFFICE IN MEMPHIS SAID CO
AUTHORS AND REQUIRE LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP TO EACH DESIGNATE
ONE WORKING GROUP
REPRESENTATIVE. AND SO AS
AMENDED RECEPTION ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX S. B. SEVEN OH TWO IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. SP SEVEN
THREE SEVEN CALIFORNIA STUDENT
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS PROGRAM
IT IS A DEEP PASS. MOTION AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM S. B. THREE FOUR
THREE SIX THREE SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN IS OUT FIVE TO TWO.
MOVING TO SENATOR MCGUIRE S. B.
TWELVE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PLANNING AND ZONING WILDFIRES.
IT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE. AND I
DO PASS A MOTION. SENATE BILL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR FOURTEEN. HI
FOURTEEN OH FIVE BATES. BATES
NO BRADFORD BY FRED HI JOAN YOU
KNOW JONES NO COMMA- HI
PROMOTER. LAYERED HI LETTERED
BY WHAT COUNTS HI OKAY ARE.
BIRDS FIVE TWO. SO I B. TWELVE
IS OUT FIVE TO. SB SIX NINE AND
SEE A TRANSFER OF AWAY GREAT
REDWOOD TREE AGENTS CITY.
RECEPTION THE FROM S. B. SIXTY
SIX. WEST PEACE NINE IS OUT
SEVENTY ZERO EIGHT P. A. KOMMER
FISHING. IT IS A DO PASS OVER
SO THE ROLE FROM S. P. SIX WEST
EIGHTY IS SEVEN ZERO. AS P.
NINETY EIGHT PUBLIC PEACE MEDIA
ACCESS- WE HAVE AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ALLOW
ACCESS ONLY UPON RECEIVING
AUTHORIZATION FROM THE
COMMANDING OFFICER ON THE
SCENE. YOU TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON SB NINETY EIGHT AS
AMENDED. SENATE BILL NINETY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR FORTINO HI FORTINO.
FIVE BATES. BRADFORD JONES HI
JONES HI COM LOG I HAVE COME
BUY LAYERED HI LATER HI WHAT
KIND OF HI MAKOWSKI. BRAUGHER
II. VOTERS TO ZERO SO S. B.
NINE EIGHT IS OUT SIX ZERO SP
OH SIX PROCEDURE BILL OF RIGHTS
THE PASSWORD THE ROLE FOR S. B.
C. SIX SO SPEAK TO US IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO I SPEAK TO EIGHTY
FIVE CALIBER TOURISM ACT WE
HAVE OFFERED TO MEMBERS A
COUPLE OF THERE WERE SO ZERO
FOR MUST BE SIXTIES WEST TO
EIGHTY FIVE IS SEVEN ZERO
THAT'S FIVE FIVE LOCAL AGENCY
TRANSIT I CONCEDE. COLLECTIONS
TO DO PASS MOSHE NUMBER SO ROLE
FROM S. B. SO SP FIVE FIVE FIVE
IS OUT SEVEN TWO AS B. SIXTEEN
HABITAT REST IN ACTED AS A DO
PASS AND WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX- SO SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO
MOVING ON TO SENATOR MELINDA
AND MELINDA IS ON SB SEVEN TWO
TWO INTERSCHOLASTIC ATHLETES
CPR TRAINING TO DO PASS AND
WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. B. SEVENTY TWO
WITHOUT SEVEN TWO ZERO MOVING
TO SENATOR MAN SP TWO SIX FOUR
FIRE ON STATE PROPERTIES TO DO
PASS THE MOTION AND WE'RE
SUBZERO FROM SP THREE FOR THREE
SO I SPEAK TO SIX FORCED OUT
FIVE TWO TWO SB SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN SIX AND PACE PROGRAM
ENERGY AUDITS WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO SPECIFY AUDIT AND
AUDIT REQUIREMENTS AND WE HAVE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO CHANGE
CRITERIA FOR THE DISBURSEMENT
OF FUNDS. AS AMENDED RECEPTION
ROLE FROM SP THREE FOR THREE
AND SO THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE TO
TWO SP FIVE HUNDRED AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES ZERO EMISSIONS HAVE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS REQUIRES YOU
HAVE TO SEARCH THAT
CERTIFICATION AS A CONDITION
FOR AV PERMIT ISSUANCE AND
STRIKE REGISTRATION PROVISION
SO WE HAVE TO MANY AMENDMENTS
TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION TO
TWENTY THIRTY AS AMENDED
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE AND SO S. P.
FIVE HUNDRED IS OUT FIVE TO
TWO. SB SEVEN NINETEEN TUSTIN
M. C. A. S. EXAMS SURPLUS LANDS
HAVE AUTHORS MMS TO SPECIFY
AFFORDABILITY. REQUIREMENTS FOR
HOUSING UNITS PERMITTED IN THE-
WE'RE- IN THE ROLL CALL FROM S.
P. SIXTY. OR A MAN. SB
SEVENTEEN MOVES OUT. ZERO
LIVING TO SENATOR AT TWO TWO
HEALTH ORDERS AND- PROVIDER RE-
WE- A PASS IMMERSIVE IN A ROW
FROM S. THREE FOR THREE. SIX B.
TWO FOUR TWO OUT FOR TO ADD TWO
SIX OH HELL STATE XP. IS A DO
PASS AND RECEPTION OR FOR MOST
SIXTY S. TWO SO SIX IS OUTSIDE
Z. AS B. TWO C. THREE C. TWO.
FOR QUOTAS. WE HAVE AUTHORS A
MEMBER TO REMOVE SUSPEND AND
RATHER. PENALTY SOME OF
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
AUTHORIZED BOARD TO TAKE IN.
ACTIONS WE ARE. SEPT THE ROLE
OF THREE FOUR THREE SO AMENDED
THREE SICK TWO MOVES OUT OF.
FIVE TWO SP FIVE A THREE CALA
NEW VOTE PRO. YEP AUTHORS ARE
MEMBERS. FROM TO TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND WE DO A ROLL CALL
ON SP FIVE EIGHTY THREE. SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHT THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
FORTINO HI FORTINO. HI BATES.
BRAD I RECORD HI JOE. NO JONES
NO COMMA. HI COM LONGER BY
LAYERED BY LAYER HI MY- HI
BECAUSE- HI. IS FIVE TO ONE. S.
P. FIVE EIGHT IS OUT TO FIVE TO
ONE SIX THREE SO AND HELP
FACILITY. SO REPORT IT TO PAY
WE'RE GONNA SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE
FOR THREE FORTY THREE. AND SO
S. B. SIXTY SEVEN IS OUT FIVE
TWO TWO. SB SIX SIX AS ON
INITIAL ARE FOR AND RE TO.
COMPENSATION FOR. IT IS A DEEP
PASS SOMEWHERE. THE ROPE. FROM
THREE FOUR THREE SO AS B. SIX
SIX ZERO IS OUT. TO TWO S. B.
SIX ONE. FARMING HOME LOAN
PROGRAM IN THE CITY PASS THE
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SIXTY
SP SIXTY SIX SP SIX SIX ONE IS
OUT. SEVEN TWO ZERO. I'M MOVING
TO SENATOR NIELSEN SP SEVENTY
SIX EXCLUDE EMPLOYEE BINDING
ARBITRATION. IT IS A DO PASS
FOR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
SB SIXTY SIX SP SEVENTY SIX IS
OUT SEVEN ZERO.AS B. TWO THREE
TWO EDT POLICIES AND PRACTICES-
IT IS A DO PASS OVER
SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM S. P.
SIXTY SIX. AND SO I SPEAK THREE
TWO THREE TWO IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO. THAT'S BEFORE NINETY ONE
CIGARETTE TOBACCO PRODUCTS
LICENSING ACT TO DO PASS AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM S. P. SIXTY SIX. JUST
BEFORE NINETY ONE IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO. MOVING TO CENTER A CHILL
ABOVE. ON SP THREE THREE SIX
PUBLIC HEALTH COVER NINETEEN
PREVENTION PROTECTION AND RE
OPEN ORDERS IT IS A DO PASS OR
SUBSTITUTING THE WRONG FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. SP THREE THREE SIXES
OUT SEVEN ZERO SP SIX OH ONE
PERSONAL INCOME TAXES EXCLUSION
CAPITAL GAIN SALE OF RESIDENCE.
WE HAVE AMENDMENTS TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO MAKE IT CONTINGENT
UPON APPROPRIATION SO AS
AMENDED WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE. RECIPE SIXTY SIX SP SIX A
ONE IS OUT SEVEN ZERO SB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE PRESCHOOL PARENT
PARTICIPATION PILOT PROGRAM WE.
HAVE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
REMOVE THE APPROPRIATION. AND
MAKE THE- AND UPON IT APART-
AND WE'RE SUPPOSED THE ROLE FOR
MY SIX SIX AMENDED SPC TO. IS
PASSED SEVENTY ZERO HAVING THE
DOCTOR. SP SEVENTEEN OFFICER
RACIAL AND FOR TO MAKE CHANGE
TO OUR I DUTY AND FINDINGS AND
ADD AUTHOR- AS AMENDED
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOUR SO THREE SEVEN PASS
FIVE TO TWO. SPEAK TO FIVE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE TO STAY. TO
DO A WE TAKE A CALL ON SB TWO
FIFTH. SEVEN SKEWS ME SENT BILL
TWO FIFTY DO THIS FLOOR SENATOR
HI FOR FIVE BAY. BRADFORD READ
HI JONES NO JONES LONGER HI
KAMAGRA LAYER ON LAYER HI OKAY
HI WHAT COUNTS II THE IS. FIVE
TO ONE. OKAY SO S. B. TWO FIFTY
IS FIVE ONE AS B. TWO FIFTY
SIX. OUR AIM- IT IS A D. PASS
SEPT THE ROLE FROM S. SIXTY SIX
TWO SIX IS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO AS
B. TWO C. NINE ALSO CAL DENTAL
IMPROVE PROGRAM. IT IS A DO
PASS HAVE ROLE CALL FROM SB SIX
SIX SP TWO SEVENTY NINE IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO SP THREE OH SIX
MEDIC COW TREATMENT AND TESTING
FOR SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
DISEASES HAVE AUTHORS MMS TO
CLARIFY HOME TESTINGMANDATE
AND THEIR SUB FOR SUB ZERO FROM
SP THREE FOR THREE SO SP THREE
OF SIX IS OUT FIVE TO TWO. AS
BEFORE TO PERSONAL SERVICE
CONTRACTS STATE EMPLOYEES.
PHYSICIAN AND PROFESSIONAL.
READ DOES IT DO PASS OR ANNUAL
ROLE AND ASK TO. SET BILL FORTY
TWO THE MOTION IS TO THE SENATE.
SENATOR FORTINO HI FORTINO.
BASE. BATES NO BREAD FOR EFFORT
HI JONES JONES NO PROBLEM
LONGER HI TOM LOGGER BY LAYER
BY LAYER HI OKAY HI OKAY BY
VOTERS. FIVE TO TWO. BEST
BEFORE TO OUT. FIVE TWO SP FOR
SIXTY TERM HEALTH PATIENT REP.
IT IS A TWO PACK SO ROLE FOR US
SIXTY SIX AND SO AS BEFORE
SIXTY IS OUT SEVENTY ZERO AS
BEFORE TEN COVERAGE COVER
NINETEEN AND I MEAN WITHOUT
COST SHARING. WE HAVE AUTHORS A
MEMBERS TO MAKE THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS RETROACTIVE TO THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC AND
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A ROLL CALL AN
SP FIVE TEN. SENATE BILL FIVE
TENEMOS IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
FORTINO NINE FORTINO FIVE BATES
NO BATES- BRADFORD ARE.
BRADFORD HI JONES NO JONES NO
LONGER HI KAMAGRA BUY LAYERED
ON LAYERED HI WHAT COUNTY. HI
MICHALSKI HI FOLKS FIVE TO TWO.
THIRTY FIVE TEN IS OUT FOR TO
TWO SPEAK. SIX EIGHT DOCTOR
PRODUCT MAN IS TO PASSWORD A
ROLL CALL. AND SIX EIGHT SENATE
BILL FIVE SICK EIGHT EMOTION DO
PASS THIS ON FLOOR SENATE
REPORT TEEN. HI FOURTEEN FIVE
CENTER BAY HI BATES ALL RIGHTS
AND- BRADFORD HI BRADFORD BY
JONES NO JONES NO COM LOGGER HI.
FROM LAGER HI LAYERED ALL RIGHT
LAYERED WHAT KASKY HI KELSEY I
VOTERS TO ONE. S. P. FIVE SIX
EIGHT IS THAT SICK. TO ONE. THE
MOVING TO S. FIVE NINE A OUNCE.
REGIONAL DISTRICT AND REAL.
WERE SEPT TO DO FIRST IN THE
FROM A THREE THREE. SIXTY FIVE
NINE IS AN FIVE TO TWO. S. B.
FORTY- VACCINATE SITES
PICKETING IT IS A CALL AND IT'S
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
BILL SEVEN FORTY TWO MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
FORTINO HI FORTINO FIVE BATES
HI BATES FIVE BRADFORD ARE
BRADFORD HI JONES NO. JONES NO
COM LOGGER HI FROM WATER I
LATER ALL RIGHT LATER I'M
WORKING ON. HI OKAY HI VOTERS
TO ONE SB SEVEN FOUR IS OUT SIX
TO FIFTH MOVING TO SAN PORT
TINO SP FORTY SCHOOL AND PLAYED.
HEALTH TRAIN PROGRAM WE HAVE A
MA'AM INSTEAD COOP COMMITTEE
MEMBER SAID CO AUTHORS- AND SO
WE'RE SUBSIDIZING THE ROLE FROM
S. P. SIXTY SIX. AND SO S. B.
FOURTEEN IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO
SP FIFTEEN HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
INCENTIVE REZONING OF IDLE
RETAIL WE HAVE AUTHORS OMITTED
CO AUTHORS AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
S. B. THREE FOUR THREE. SO AS
AMENDED SB FIFTEEN IS OUT FIVE
TO TWO SP FORTY FIVE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION SAFE DRINKING WATER
DROP FOR. PREPARATION AND FLOOD
PROTECTION BOND ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. IT IS A TWO PAST
SUMMER SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM S. B. THREE FOUR THREE SIX
B. FORTY FIVE IS OUT FIVE TO
TWO. AS B. TWO TO FOUR ON
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATION
WE HAVE A MOMENT- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES REGARDING THE
INSTRUCTION AND CO AUTHORS. AND
THAT IS A SUBSTITUTE OF SB
SIXTY SIX SP TWO TO FORCE OUT
SEVEN TO ZERO. AS B. TWO THREE
SEVEN STUDENT DYSLEXIA HEALTH
SCREENING WE HAVE AUTHORS IN
THEM INSTEAD DYSLEXIA SCREENING
FOR STUDENTS IN THIRD. GRADE
AND IT CO AUTHORS. TEN
RECEPTION THE ROLE FOR S. B. C.
SIX. AND SO AS B. TWO THREE SO
IS OUT SEVEN ZERO TWO FIVE
HEALTH AND EMPLOYER SO. LARGE
GROUP HEALTH AND- WE HAVE
AUTHORS MENACING. RELATIONSHIP
HAVE ENDED AND CAN CONTRACT
WERE SO ROLE FROM S. SIXTY. S.
P. TWO FIVE IS OUT SEVEN TO
ZERO. SP THREE EIGHTY SR SEVEN
TEN PROPERTY CITY SOUTH
PASADENA HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO INCLUDE HISTORIC
HOME SALES REQUIRE CONTRAST
INSPECT AND REPAIR CERTAIN
HOMES. AND REQUIRE PROCEEDS TO
BE TRANSFERRED TO SOUTH
PASADENA. AS AMENDED WERE
SUBSTITUTED THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX AND SO SP THREE
EIGHTY ONE IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO. SP THREE EIGHT SEVEN
PEACE OFFICER CERTIFICATION WE
HAVE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES WERE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. SP THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SP
FOUR FIVE SEVEN PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS INVESTMENTS
FROM TURKEY. IT IS A DEEP PASS
AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX SO IT'S
BEFORE FIVE SEVEN IS OUT OF
SEVEN TO ZERO. AS BEFORE EIGHT
FIVE INCOME TAX CREDIT CERTIFY
STUDIO CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS WE
HAVE AUTHORS MM INSTEAD CO
AUTHORS. AND SO THAT BILL WERE
SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY
SIX SO THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO. SP FIVE SIXTY TWO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. FOR
AUTISM WE HAVE AUTHORS MMS TO
EXPAND ENTITIES THAT CAN
PROVIDE CERTIFICATION AND
CREDENTIALING SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX SP FIVE
SIX TWO IS OUT OF SEVEN TO
ZERO. SB SIX TWELVE ELECTRICAL
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS
ALLOCATION OF LEGACY RESOURCES.
HAVE AUTHORS MMS MAKE CHANGES
RELATED TO LONG TERM RENEWABLE
ENERGY. AND WERE ACCEPTED IN A
ROW FROM S. B. THREE FOUR THREE
SIX B. SIX TWELVE IS OUT FIVE
TO TWO. SB SEVEN FIFTEEN
HUNTING LICENSE VERIFICATION WE
HAVE AUTHORS MMS TO MAKE
CHANGES RELATED TO THE LOANING
IN TRANSFERRING FIREARMS LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPORTING AND OTHER
HANGES. ARE SUBSTANTIVE ROLE
FROM SP. THREE FOUR THREE SIX
B. SEVEN FIFTEEN IS HOW. FIVE
TO TWO SB SEVEN EIGHT. PRIVATE
YOU. WE HAVE MANY MEMBERS TO
STRIKE MANDATORY MINIMUM TERM
PROVISIONS AND SO. ARE SUCH THE
ROLE OF S. B. SO. SB SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT AS AMENDED IS OUT
SEVENTY. TWO ZERO. MOVING THE
GENERAL ROTH SP NINE SEVEN ONE
DAY- FROM MATEER FOR PAY. IT IS
A TWO PACK. RECEPTION THE FROM
S. SIXTY SO S. B. NINETY SEVEN.
MOVES SEVEN ZERO SP THREE
FIFTEEN WE'RE BACK REVOCABLE
TRANSFER OF DEATH HE JUST TO DO
PASS RECEPTION IN THE ROLE OF
SB SIXTY SIX. FIFTY THREE
FIFTEEN PASSES SEVEN ZERO SB
SIX OH SEVEN PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS. WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO REMOTE HEARING
PARTICIPATION AND MAKE OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES WE'RE GONNA
ROLL CALL VOTE ON SB SIX OH
SEVEN. SENATE BILL SIX ZERO
SEVEN THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR FORTINO. I. FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED. SENATOR ALL RIGHT BRED
FOR I JONES HI JOAN HI COMMA.
LATER I COME ANDRADE LAYERED ON
LAYER BY WHAT KASKY HI MAKOWSKI
ARE PRODUCE A TO ZERO THAT'S
BASIC OR SEVEN OUT SIX TO ZERO
SIX SIX DISABLED PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION EXECUTOR
ADMINISTRATOR CLAIMANTS A STATE
WE HAVE A DO PASS OR SUBSIDY
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX SP
SIX SIX SEVEN IS OUT SEVEN ZERO
SB SEVEN FIVE FIVE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING RELATED
JOB PLACEMENT REPORTING I TO
DO PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM
SB SIXTY SIX. THREE SEVEN FIVE
FIVE IS OUT SEVEN ZERO SB SEVEN
SEVEN ZERO LAW SCHOOL PATHWAYS
PROGRAM WE HAVE AMENDMENTS FOR
OFFERED TO REMOVE THE
APPROPRIATION AND MAKE THE
PROGRAM CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION WOULD DO A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER FORTINO
HI FORTINO. BY BATES. BRADFORD
ON BRADFORD HI JONES. NO JONES
NO COMMA. I'M LOGGED BY LAYER
ON LAYER BY MY COUNT SKI HI
MAKOWSKI HI. FOR TO ONE SB
SEVEN SO ZERO FIVE ONE SPC SO
THREE COUNT CARE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS FOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SIR FOR AGE CHILDREN A DEEP.
MOTION NUMBER SUB IN THE RAW
FROM S. B. SIXTIES S. SEVEN
SEVEN THREE IS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO S. B. A. HUNDRED OF ESTATE
AND BUREAU REAL ESTATE. DO PASS
MY AND WE SUBSIDY IN THE ROLE
FROM SB SIX SIX SP A HUNDRED IS
OUT SEVEN ZERO SP EIGHT OH ONE
BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES TO
DO PASS AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB SIXTY SIX
SP EIGHT A ONE IS OUT SEVEN.
TWO ZERO SB EIGHT OH TWO BUREAU
PRIVATE SECONDARY EDUCATION IS
TO DO PASS OR SUBSIDY THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX AND SO S. B.
EIGHT OH TWO WAS OUT SEVEN TO
ZERO SP EIGHT OH THREE BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY IT IS
A DEEP PASS WE'RE GONNA DO A
ROLL CALL AT S. B. EIGHT OH
THREE. SENATE BILL EIGHT ZERO
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR FORTINO HI
FORTINO. FIVE BATES ALL RIGHT.
EIGHT BRADFORD OUR BRADFORD I
JOE. HI JONES HI COM LAGER HI
FROM LONGER BY LATE. ALL RIGHT
LATER HI WHAT OF SKI HI
RECOUNTS THE FIVE. BOAT SEVEN
TO. THE SPEED OF IS OUT SEVEN
IS. SP EIGHT US MEDIC BOARD OF.
WE HAVE. MMS TO EXTEND. AND
MAKE CHANGES THE BOARD. AND
RACE FOR AND IT'S A ROLL CALL.
SENATE BILL EIGHT ZERO SIX
EMOTIONS TO PASS AMENDED THE
SENATE FOR. CENTER FOR. HI
FORTINO FIVE BATES. BRADFORD HI
BRADFORD BY JONES. COM LARGER
COMMA GARAGE LAYER HI LAYERED
HI WHAT CAN GAY I BUT SKI- HI
THEY I BATES BY LOTUS ZERO SBA
DOES IS THAT SIX ZERO. MOVING
TO SENATOR. AS TWENTY THREE
DISTRICT OF INTIMATE IT'S A DO
PASS FOR SUCH THEY'RE ALL FROM
S. B. SO OF US TWENTY THREE IS
OUT ZERO. SB SEVEN COMPOSE
COMPILE EDUCATION CAN. HAVE AND
LET THE BILLS WERE TO PUBLIC
SCHOOL AND AT THE FINDINGS IN
DECORATIONS OR SUBSTITUTE ROLL
CALL FROM A THREE FOR THREE
SIZE AND SB SEVENTY PASS FIVE
TWO. AS P. SEVENTY RED PROPERTY
INSURANCE WILDFIRE RISK GROUP.
IT'S A DO PASS AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX SB SEVENTY TWO
PASSES- SEVENTY ZERO SP THREE
TEN UNUSED CANCER MEDICATION
RECYCLING OF AUTHORS ARE
MEMBERS TO CAP THE NUMBER OF
PHYSICIANS WHO MAY PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM RECEPTION THE
ROLL CALL FROM S. P. SIXTY SIX.
AS AMENDED SB THREE TEN PASSES
SEVEN ZERO S. BEFORE TWENTY SIX
MUNICIPAL SEPARATE STORM SEWER
SYSTEM FINANCE CAPACITY
ANALYSIS IT'S A DO PASS. OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX INTEREST BEFORE
TWENTY SIX PASSES SEVEN TWO
ZERO S. BEFORE EIGHT TEACHER
CREDENTIALING READING
ASSESSMENTS TO DO PASS
RECEPTION IN THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX SO THAT'S BEFORE
EIGHT EIGHT PASSES SEVEN TO
ZERO. SP FIVE THREE SEVEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD CHILD
WELFARE WE HAVE A COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO STRIKE THE COURT
DETERMINATION PROVISIONS SO AS
AMENDED RECEPTION IN THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX AND SP THREE
FIVE FIVE THREE SEVEN PASSES.
ON A SEVEN ZERO VOTES SP FIVE
THREE EIGHT INVESTING WIRELESS
PROTECTIVE ORDERS WE HAVE MEDIA
MEMBERS TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON SB FIVE THREE EIGHT. SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
FORTINO NINE FOURTEEN OH FIVE
SENATOR BATES. BATES BY SENATOR
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT BRADFORD HI
SENATOR JONES HI JONES FIVE
CENTER COMPLEX HI COMMA GARAGE
CENTER LAYERED ON SENATOR
LAYERED AUDIENCE EVERYONE
CASKEY. HI IN ORDER THE- SEVEN
DAYS A- THREE FIVE THREE EIGHT
PASS SEVEN. SP FIVE SIX SO
CLIMATE. REDUCTION HOME
INITIATIVE. WE HAVE A-
COMMITTEE TO MAKE CONTINUED
APPROACH. WE'RE GONNA ROLL CALL
THE- SENATE BILL FIVE SIX ZERO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMANDA
TO THE SENATE. CENTERPOINT HI
FORTINO I HEY NO BATES NO BREAD
HI BRAD HI JONES NO JONES NO
COM LAGER HI LAGER ON LAYER ON.
LATER OF ICE MY CASKEY. HI MY
ARE. THOSE FIVE. THIRTY FIVE
SIXTY IS OUT. FIVE TO. MOVING
ON S. B. C. SEVEN A ON THE
COMPANY WOMEN X. HOMELESS TO
TWENTY ONE IS O PASS. AND
WE'RE SO THE ROLE FROM A B. SIX
SIX B. B. S. B. SIX EIGHT SEVEN
IS HERE S. B. EIGHT TO TRY
CRIME HEALTH CAN. IT IS WE HAVE
COME MEMBERS MAKE INTO UPON. OR
SO EITHER CALL FROM B. SIX SIX
SP SIX EIGHT TWO PASS SEVEN SP
EIGHT OH SIX NOT FOR PERFORMING
ARTS OR- HEY RON FAMOUS SERVICE
AND GRANTS WE HAVE AUTHORS MMS
TO MODIFY THE MATCHING FUNDS
SCHEDULING WE HAVE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT A CO AUTHOR.
WHEN YOU ROLL CALL VOTE ON SB
EIGHT OH FIVE SENATE BILL EIGHT
ZERO FIVE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR FORTINO HI FORTINO ON.
BATES BRADFORD. BY DRIVE HI JOE.
NO JONES NO. LONGER HI FROM
ANDRADE. ONLINE LAYERED. WHAT
KASKY HI MAKOWSKI HI BILL THIS.
EIGHT NO. BURRIS FIVE TO TWO SO
S. B. EIGHT OH FIVE OUT. FIVE
TO TWO MOVING ON TO SEND
SKINNER- ESPYS. PIECE OFFICE
RECORD WE HAVE FATHERS MEMBER
SAID SIR REQUIRE TO GO A
RETENTION AND- OTHER CHANGES
HAVE COMMITTEE. TO STRIKE THAT
AND I ATTORNEY FEE- WE'RE
SUBJECT THE RAW FOR MR THREE
FOR THREE SO I AMENDED SB
SIXTEEN FIVE TO TWO SP EIGHTEEN
GREEN HYDROGEN WE HAVE AUTHORS
MMC CLARIFIED THAT THE CPUC CAN
CONSIDER GREEN ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN AS PART OF A FUTURE
PROCEEDINGS. AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB SIXTY SIX TWO AS AMENDED SB
EIGHTEEN PASSES SEVEN ZERO SP
TWENTY SIX STUDENT ATHLETE
COMPENSATION WE HAVE AUTHORS A
MINISTER'S GROUP TO REMOVE THE
SERRA SEVERABILITY CLAUSE. AND
THE PROVISION ALLOWING STUDENTS
TO RECOUP ATTORNEY'S FEES AND
AS AMENDED OR SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX AND SO
SB TWENTY SIX PASSES SEVEN ZERO
SB TWENTY SEVEN NATURAL AND
WORKING LAND REGISTRY OF CARBON
SEQUESTRATION PROJECTS. WE HAVE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO LOW CARB
TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION OF A
PART OF THE REGISTRY INTO A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON SB TWENTY
SEVEN. SENATE BILL SENATE BILL
TWENTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER FORTINO HI FORTINO
HI BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD R.
BRADFORD HI JONES NO JONES NO
COM LAGER I KAMAGRA LAYERED HI
LAYERED HI WORKOUTS SKI HI
MAKOWSKI OUR. BOGUS FIVE TO TWO
SP TWENTY SEVEN IS A FIVE TO
TWO- SP SIX FIVE IS A DEEP.
RECEPTION THE WRONG FROM SP
FOURTH STRAIGHT SIXTY FIVE. BY
TO TWO. SP EIGHTY ONE CENTS AND
HAS- IT IS A TO PAY. AND WE'RE
SUBS FOR SP THREE FOURTHS. AND
SO SP EIGHTY ONE PASSES OUT OF
TO TWO VOTE AS B. TWO. DENSITY
LAW CENTER FOR MODERN IS TO
HOUSING. IT IS A DO PASS FOR
SUB THE ROLE FROM SP FOURTHS.
TO SPEAK TO NOW PACK. FIVE TWO
TWO FIFTY SP THREE FOUR FIVE
YOUTH. PLACEMENT WE HAVE
AUTHORS A THIS. THE CHILD WILL
CAN PROVIDE REPORTS ITS EGGS
WORK. WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX AS
AMENDED SB THREE FIVE FOUR
PASSES SEVEN ZERO. SP FIVE
TWENTY FOR HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
PATIENTS HEARING. WE HAVE A
WE'RE GONNA ROLL CALL THOUGH TO
DO PASS AN SP FIVE TO FOUR.
SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTENT TINA HI.
FORTINO FIVE BATES. BRADFORD BY
BRADFORD HI JOE. HI JOE BY COM
LONGER AND COME LATER ON LET.
HI LATER BY CASKEY. HI MY CALS
HI. WHAT IS TWO ZERO AS P. FIVE
TWO IS THAT SIX DAYS A S. B. C.
FOUR. WE HAVE AUTISM ASSIST TO
SEE E. O. COM STATEMENT IN HIGH
REVENUE RATHER BUSINESS STAY
REQUIRE. AND SO AS A WITH ROLE
FROM SP. THREE FOR THREE ZERO
THREE SEVEN FORTY SIX IS OUT
FIVE TO TWO MOVING TO SENATOR
STERN SP. SIXTY THREE FIRE
PREVENTION IT'S A DO PASS. MOST
WE'RE GONNA SEPT. THE ROLE FROM
SP SIXTY OR SIX THREE. SEVEN
TWO ZERO SP TWO EIGHT FOUR.
WORKERS COMP AND FIRE AND P.
FIVE PIECE OFFICERS POSE.
STRESS IT'S A DO PASS. OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S.
B. THREE FOUR THREE FOR THREE
TO SPEAK TO A FOUR PASSES FIVE
TO TWO. SP TWO NINE ONE STUDENT
ADVISORY COUNCIL IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THE SCOPE.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX AND SO
S. B. TWO NINE ONE PASSES
SEVEN. ZERO AS BEFORE- SIX OIL
AND GAS OPERATIONS DATA
AVAILABILITY WE HAVE AUTHORS
MMS TO MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES
WERE GONNA ROLL CALL VOTE ON SP
FOUR OH SIX. SENATE BLL FOUR
ZERO SIX THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FORTINO. I FOURTEEN FIVE BATES.
BRADFORD BY BRADFORD BY I THANK.
HI LAYERED HI LAYERED HI MY
CASKEY HI MAKOWSKI HI. VOTED
SIX TO ZERO AS BEFORE SIX IS
OUT SIX ZERO S. BEFORE TWENTY
THREE ENERGY RENEWABLE AND ZERO
CARBON RESOURCES WE HAVE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
REQUIREMENTS THAT C. E. C.
UPDATE RECOMMENDATIONS AMONG
OTHER THINGS AND AS A MENTOR
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM S. B. THREE FOUR THREE
JUST BEFORE TWO THREE PASSES
FIVE TO TWO SP FIVE THREE THREE
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLANS MICRO
GRIDS. WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO DELETE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR SURE CPUC AND-
YES TO CONVENE PUBLIC HEARINGS
WERE GONNA ROLL CALL VOTE ON SP
FIVE THREE THREE SENATE BILL
FIVE THIRTY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FORTINO HI FORTINO.
HI BATES. BRADFORD BYE BYE HI
JONES NO. JONES NO PROBLEM.
COMMA BY LAYER. HI LAYERED FIVE
OKAY. HI MICHAEL. FIVE BOOK IS
TO ONE. PRESS FIVE THREE IS OUT
FIVE TO ONE SP FIVE FIVE ONE-CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC VEHICLE
AUTHORITY. WE HAVE AUTHORS MMS
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES WE'RE
GONNA SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR
SP THREE FOR THREE SO AS
AMENDED. SP FIVE FIVE ONE
PASSES FIVE TO TWO SP FIVE
EIGHT TWO ON CLIMATE CHANGE WE
HAVE AUTHORS MMS INTEGRATE
PROPOSAL. POSED ACTIVITIES INTO
EXISTING STATE EFFORTS AS
AMENDED WERE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM S. B. THREE FOUR
THREE. AND SO S. B. FIVE EIGHT
TWO AS AMENDED PASSES FIVE TO
TWO SB SIX FIVE- SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES FINANCIAL
REPORTING. WE HAVE AMENDMENTS.
WERE OFFERED TO REDUCE OUR
COSTS AND WE HAVE TOO MANY
AMENDMENTS TO REDUCE THE SCOPE.
AND AS AMENDED WE ARE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
S. B. THREE FOUR THREE. AND SO
THE BILL. PASSES FIVE TO TWO-
ESPYS NINE THREE. FOR J. IN.
EDUCATION WE HAVE AUTHORS MMS
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT TO
ESTABLISH A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. SO AS
AMENDED RECEPTION ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX AND SO S. BE SIX FOOT
SIX NINETY THREE AS AMENDED.
PASSES SEVENTY ZERO SB SEVEN
NINE- WILDFIRE CONNECTIVITY
BARRIERS HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE NUMBER
OF PROJECTS. AND WE ARE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX AS AMENDED SB. SEVEN
NINETY PASSES SEVEN ZERO.
MOVING TO SENATOR AMBERG SP
THIRTY FOUR STUDENTS SUCCESS
CARDS FOR PUBLIC LIBRARIES
MA'AM AS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. AND WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE
FROM SP THREE FOR THREE AS
AMENDED SB THIRTY FOUR PASSES
FIVE TO TWO SP FORTY ONE.
PRIVACY GENETIC TESTING
COMPANIES IT'S A DO PASS WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. SP FORTY ONE PASSES
SEVEN ZERO SB FORTY NINE INCOME
TAX CREDITS CLIFORNIA FAIR
FEES TAX CREDITS TO DO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX SO AS- SO AS BEFORE
NINE PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO. AS
B. TWO FOUR ONE CIVIL ACTIONS
WE HAVE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
DELETE THE REQUIREMENT FOR
RECORDED VIDEO TESTIMONY. AND
WE HAVE A COMMITTEE MM INSTEAD
A SUNSET DATE SO SP TWO FOR ONE
AS AMENDED WERE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX
PASSES SEVEN. ZERO SP THREE
FOUR NINE CALIFORNIA. ETHICAL
TREATMENT FOR PERSONS WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. WE ARE
DOING IT TO PASS AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
S. P. SIXTY SIX SP TWO FOUR
NINE PASSES SEVEN ZERO. SP
THREE SIX SIX AUTOMOBILE
DISMANTLING TASK FORCES TO DO
PASS. RECOMMENDATION OR MOTION
AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM S. P. SIXTY SIX SP
THREE SIX SIX PASSES SEVENTY
ZERO. SP THREE NINE NINE
SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATES
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS DO PASS AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX SP THREE NINE
NINE PASSES SEVEN ZERO S.
BEFORE TWENTY. UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE INTEGRITY PROGRAM IT
IS A TWO PASS AND WHERE'S
SUBSIDY ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX
AND SO AS BEFORE TWENTY PASSES
SEVENTY ZERO SB SIX SIX FIVE
EMPLOYMENT POLICY VETERANS
PREFERENCES. WE HAVE TOO MANY
AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE BUSINESS
REPORT THE ADOPTION OF A POLICY
INCLUDE A SUNSET AND ALLOW VETS
WHO WERE DISCHARGEDUNDER DON'T
ASK DON'T TELL. TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM AND WE'RE GONNA
DO. A ROLL CALL VOTE. SAN BILL
SIX SIX FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE.
SENATOR PORTENT TINO HI FORTINO
FIVE BAYH. I BAITS ARE AND
BRADFORD ARE BRED FIVE JOE. HI
JONES II CENTER COM LOGGER I
FROM WATER ICE CENTER LAYER BY.
LAYER OF ICE AND- WHAT COUNTY.
K. VOTED SIX TO ZERO. SO THAT
BILL IS OUT SIX TO ZERO AS
AMENDED WE HAVE SP SIX SIX SIX
CIVIL LITIGATION WE HAVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION RECEPTION THE
ROLE ON SB SIXTY SIX SO THAT
BILLS APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY
SEVEN ZERO. AS AMENDED MOVING
TO SENATOR WHITE COW SKI SP
THIRTY EIGHT BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS WE HAVE AUTHORS MMS
ALLOW THE STEWARDSHIP
ORGANIZATION A CONTRACT WITH
CURBSIDE DROP RAIDERS SCRAP
YARDS AND TO PAY BY WEIGHT. BY
WEIGHT WE HAVE A CURRENT
PARTICIPANTS TO MAINTAIN
STANDING AND OTHER CHANGES AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SP THREE FOR THREE SO AS
AMENDED SB THIRTY EIGHT PASSES
FIVE TWO. SP FORTY TWO E. T. S.
C. FORD ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY IS
A DO PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE
FROM SB SIXTY SIX AND SO SP
FORTY TWO PASSES SEVEN ZERO SP
THREE FOR SIX IN VEHICLE
CAMERAS. TO DO PAST SUMMER
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE THAT BILL IS.
APPROVED FIVE TO TWO. A FIVE OH
ONE CLAIMS AGAINST PUBLIC
ENTITIES WE HAVE AUTHORS ARE
MEMBERS TO APPLY PROVISIONS TO
PARTIES WERE SEEKING COURT
RELIEF. AS AMENDED RECEPTION TO
THE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX SP
FIVE OH ONE AS AMENDED PASSES
SEVENTY ZERO. SP EIGHT- SEVENTY
F. E. H. ENFORCEMENT DO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE OF SB SIXTY
SIXTY EIGHT OH SEVEN PASSES
SEVEN TWO ZERO. MOVING ON TO
SENATOR WIENER SP TEN PLANNING
AND ZONING HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
DENSITY TO DO PASS WE'RE GONNA
ROLL CALL VOTE ON SB TENSE.
SENATE BILL TEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR FORTINO HI FORTINO HI
BATES. NO BATE'S NOSE BRADFORD
HI BRADFORD HI JONES HI JONES
HI KAAM LOGGER HI KAMAGRA BUY
LAYERED. LAYERED HI WHEN CASKEY
HI KANSKE BY VOTERS SIX ONE. SP
TEN PASSES SIXTY ONE SP ONE TEN
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT
SERVICES. IT IS A TWO PASS
RECEPTIONS IN THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX THE BILL PASSES
SEVEN. ZERO SP TWO TWO ONE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE TIMELY
ACCESS TO CARE. WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
APPLICATION OF STANDARD SUMMER
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SP
THREE FOR THREE SO AS AMENDED
SB TWO TO ONE. PASSES FIVE TO
TWO SP TWO THREE FOR TRANSITION
AGE YOUTH HOUSING PROGRAM IT'S
A DO PASS RECEPTION IN THE ROLE
OF SB SIXTY SIX. SP TWO THREE
FOUR PASSES SEVEN TO ZERO AS B.
TWO FIVE TWO TOXICOLOGY TESTING
ON DOGS AND CATS. OFFERS OUR
MEMBERS TO ALLOW TESTING WHEN
DIRECTED IN WRITING BY THE FDA
IF COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ALLOW
DRUG TESTING WHEN THERE IS AN
INDICATION THAT SIMILAR
PRODUCTS ARE ROUTINELY USED IN
ANIMAL. AND HUMAN MEDICINE AND
SO AS AMENDED WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S.
B. THREE FOUR THREE THAT'S
RIGHT SPEAK TO FIVE TWO PASSES.
FIVE TO TWO SP THREE FOURTEEN
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE PERMITS IN
COMMON LICENSING AREAS IT'S A
TWO PASS RECEPTIONS. IN THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX SP THREE
FOR PASSES TO TWO SEVEN. SP
THREE NINE THREE NINE VEHICLES
WERE USE CHARGE PRIVATE. WE
AUTHORS MM TO DELAY THE C. IS
REPORTING THAT PRICE MONTHS
MAKE. CHANGES WERE SUCH A HE
WRONG FROM SP THREE FOR SO I
AMANDA. SB THREE THREE NINE.
FIVE TO. SP THREE FIVE LOWER
FOR THE OF ENGAGING IN
PROSTITUTION. WE HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OF MOTION AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FOR
S. B. THREE FOUR THREE. SO SP
THREE FIVE SEVEN PASSES FIVE TO
TWO. SP FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
GENERAL PLAN ANNUAL REPORT WE
HAVE AMENDMENTS FROM THE AUTHOR
TO DELETE THE REQUIREMENT FOR
ATV TO VALIDATE REPORTING DATA.
AND DELAY IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
AT TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WE'RE
GONNA ROLL CALL VOTE ON SP FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN. SENATE BILL FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR FORTINO. HI.
FORTINO EYES CENTER BATES.
SENATOR BRAD OUR BRADFORD
SENATOR JONES HI. JONES I
INTERCOM LAGER HI FROM LOGGER
ICE LAYER ON. LAYER I SENT
WHITE HOUSE HI. MICHAEL ARE.
BOAT SIX TO ZERO. THAT'S BEFORE
SEVEN SEVEN PASSES SIX ZERO. SP
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT PLANNING AND
THAT'S **** AS AMENDED SIX ZERO
AS BEFORE SEVEN EIGHT PLANNING
AND ZONING LOT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS. WE HAVE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO AVOID IN
ANY COVENANTS THAT EFFECTIVELY
RESTRICT OR PROHIBIT HOUSING
SUBJECT TO A BUILT TO THE BILL
STANDARD. RENEWAL ROLL CALL
VOTE ON SP FOUR SEVEN EIGHT AS
A- SENATE BILL FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTENT TINO. HI
FORTINO FIVE BATES NO BATES NO
BRADFORD R. BRADFORD BY JONES
THANK. YOU BYE FROM LAGER HI.
HI LAYERS ARE LAYERED FIVE
WORKOUTS SKI. ACCOUNTS KEEP OUR
BOAT. IS SIX TO ONE. SO THAT
WAS- FORCE SEVEN RIGHT FOURTH
EIGHT SO WE DID FORCE SEVEN
HOURS FOR SO FAST BE SEVEN
EIGHT IS OUT WAS IT. SIX ONE
SIX TWO. SP FIVE NINETEEN THE
CRIMINAL OF CERTAIN THINGS SO.
WE HAVE OFF MMS TO STRIKE THE
CEILING RESEND FOR. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM THREE FOUR THREE SO SP
FIVE NINETEEN AS AMENDED IS OUT
FIVE TWO TWO S. B. SEVEN NINE
THREE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES MUSIC
VENUE LICENSING AND
ENTERTAINMENT SOUNDS. WE HAVE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO ESTABLISH
A MUSIC VENUE EXCHANGE FEE AND
MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES
WERE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON SB SEVEN NINETY THREE.
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FORTINO HI FORTINO FIVE BATES
NO BATES NO BRADFORD HI
BRADFORD HI JONES HI JONES BY
COM LAGER HI. PUBLIC HI LAYERED
HI LAYERED HI I CAN'T SPEAK HI
KELSEY ARE VOTED. SIX TO ONE.
SO S. PIECE NINETY THREE IS OUT
SICK ONE. MOVING ON TO SENATOR
WILL. SP THREE SIXTY ESCROW
AGENTS RAIDING SERVICES IT'S A
DO PASS WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM SB
SIXTY SIX. SO SP THREE SIXTY IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SP FIVE FOUR
FIVE STUDENT RETENTION
RESOURCES COVERT NINETEEN
IMPACT. IT IS A DO PASS WERE
SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM SB SIXTY
SIX SP FIVE FOUR FIVE IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO THREE FIVE FOUR
SIX COMMUNICATIONS LIFELINE
UNIVERSAL SERVICES. E HAVE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THE CPUC CAN SENSE THAT THE
PROGRAM UPON MEETING SPECIFIC
CRITERIA. AND SO AS AMENDED AS
BEFORE WE'RE GONNA SUBSIDY THE
ROLE FROM SB SIXTY SIX AS
AMENDED. SB FIVE FOUR SIX IS
OUT. SO TWO ZERO- THAT IS ALL
OF THE MEMBERS BUT WE DO HAVE A
TWO YEAR BILLS SO THE
FOLLOWING. TWO YEARS THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE MADE TO
YOUR BILL SOME BY AUTHORS
REQUEST SOME BY THE COMMITTEE-
SOME BILLS HAVE SOME WORK TO BE
DONE SOME. POLICY COMMITTEE
CONCERNS AND COMMITMENTS THAT
WERE MADE THAT. MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN I'M NOT GOING TO
GIVE. CLARIFICATION EACH BUT
THOSE ARE THE CATEGORIES PRETTY
MUCH SO HERE THE BILLS THAT ARE
TO YOUR BILLS. SB TWENTY ONE BY
GLAZER SP SIX SPORT TO BUY COM
LONGER SP FOUR FOUR NINE BY
STERN. AS B. TWO SIX OH BY
WINNER SP THREE SEVEN NINE BY
WINNER SP THIRTY ONE BY
CORTESE. SP THREE SIX FOUR BY
SKINNER SP THREE NINE EIGHT BY
SKINNER S. B. SEVEN SIX OH. BY
BAIT S. B. TWO THIRTY POURTANT
TINO. SP THREE OH FOUR BY ARCH
ALETTA. SO 216-402-4492. SIX OH
THREE SEVEN NINE THIRTY ONE
THREE SIX FOUR. THREE NINE
EIGHT SEVEN SIX OH TWO THREE OH
AND THREE OH FOUR ARE ALL TWO
YEAR BILLS. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS. AND ALL OF YOU HAVE A
GOOD WEEKEND- BEFORE I GAVEL
DOWN I JUST WANT TO CHECK IN
WITH MARK. AND THEN WILL THIS
MAKE SURE. FORGET ABOUT IT YOU
DON'T NEED ANY IRAQI WE'VE
CHECK RAW GOOD. HI WE HAVE NOT.
WE'RE JUST DOUBLE CHECKING ONE
THING BEFORE WE GO. THAT SHOULD
WE STAY OR GO WHAT. JUST DOUBLE
CHECKING ONE THING.
SO WE HAVE
ONE CLARIFICATION ON SP TWENTY
TWO BY SENATOR GLAZER THE
ACTUAL VOTE TALLY WAS FIVE TO
ONE- WITH SENATOR BATES NOT
VOTING SENATOR JONES VOTING NO
SO S. B. TWENTY TWO PASSES.
FIVE TO ONE. ALL RIGHT THAT
CONCLUDES THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FOR
TODAY MEETING IS ADJOURNED.